Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Ich begrüße alle hier zur einundneunzigsten Ausgabe zu unserem einundneunzigsten Gespräch und ja heute geht's,
wirklich mal um andere kosmische Angelegenheiten ähm nachdem äh wir hier auch schon so viel Konkretes äh besprochen haben
dachte ich mir wird's Zeit für die Meterebene mal auf die Meterebene zu gehen
Und heute wollen wir uns äh ja auch schon auch mit Astronomie beschäftigen und äh sicherlich auch mit Astrophysik und all diesen Dingen, mit denen wir hier sonst so viel zu tun haben, aber wir laden auch die
Philosophie noch mit ein und dazu begrüße ich erstmal meine Gesprächspartnerin für heute, nämlich die Simple Sybille Andal, hallo.
Hallo, ich freue mich sehr.
Ja, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Ähm.
Du bist da sozusagen die äh natürliche Wahl, weil du dich eben mit all diesen Dingen äh beschäftigst, die ich gerade so angeteasert habe,
mache ich ja sowieso immer, aber finde ich jetzt gerade nochmal extra interessant da mal reinzustochern, wo das bei dir eigentlich herkommt, wie wie du dich eigentlich so in all diese ganzen Welten hineinentwickelt hast. Ähm
vor Pfingsten an, schon mit.
Ja das ist tatsächlich eine etwas ungewöhnliche Geschichte bei mir. Sonst ist es ja oft so, dass ähm Astronomiebegeisterte irgendwelche Geschichten aus ihrer Kindheit erzählen können, so der Opa mit dem Teleskop oder der Vater.
Mondlandung sehr beliebt.
Ja gut, dafür bin ich ein bisschen zu jung.
Hatte ich hier schon ein paar Mal, stirbt aber langsam aus.
Ähm das gab's in der Form bei mir tatsächlich nicht ähm Vater, Künstler, Mutter, Ärztin
großer Bruder an allem interessiert nur nicht an Naturwissenschaften und insofern kam es bei mir auch relativ spät. Also meine erste Leidenschaft war eher die Kunst und das Zeichnen und
die Wiedergabe von allem was ich so um mich rum befand. Ich schieb's auch immer ein bisschen darauf, dass ich in Norddeutschland groß geworden bin, wo ja nun sehr viele Wolken den Himmel verdecken. Also ich hatte irgendwie keine besonders eindrucksvollen,
nächtlichen Erfahrungen mit Blick nach oben. Ähm meine,
Meine nächste Leidenschaft nach der Kunst war dann die Mathematik, das fand ich ganz großartig, hatte da wahnsinnig Spaß dabei, das waren dann so meine beiden Hauptinteressen in der Schule, konnte es um Mathematik.
Ähm und darüber kam dann tatsächlich auch mein erstes Interesse an der Philosophie, über ich mich gefragt habe, was was ist denn eigentlich Kunst,
so diese typische Frage, die ja in diesem schlimmen Spruch ist, dass Kunst oder kann das weg zusammengefasst ist. Ist ja schon irgendwie eine Frage, die die man sich oft stellt, aber die relativ schwierig zu beantworten ist. So, das war mein erster Verbindungspunkt zur Philosophie.
Welchem Alter ist denn diese Frage das erste Mal gekommen.
Das war so im Teenageralter. Also als ich schon relativ gut zeichnen konnte, ich konnte die Dinge so abzeichnen, dass sie so aussahen, wie sie auch aussahen,
erstmal natürlich ein Erfolg war, aber dann gleichzeitig die große Gefahr mit sich brachte, zu sagen, naja, dann kannst du auch gleich ein Foto machen. So, ist wenig gewonnen durch so eine Zeichenfähigkeit. Und ähm,
Ja, also dadurch, das war so mein erster Berührungspunkt mit der Philosophie. Dann kam als nächstes die Physik.
Moment, nochmal, aber ich meine, Mathematik und Philosophie, ich meine, wenn wenn quasi die Frage nach der Philosophie durch Mathematik
Interesse ausgelöst wird, dann ist das ja quasi auch schon so ein bisschen die Erkenntnis, würde ich jetzt mal unterstellen mit das Mathematik so quasi die universelle Sprache ist, die jetzt versucht einem irgendwie alles zu erklären,
so deuten.
Ja, das kommt dann natürlich auch dazu, ich meine, die Mathematik, die wirft er auch einfach nochmal ganz viele Fragen auf, weil sie ja,
Auf der einen Seite wichtig ist für uns, um die Natur zu beschreiben und überall eine ganz wichtige Rolle spielt in der Technologie und eigentlich in fast allen Wissenschaften. Aber dann auch diesen komischen Status hat, das ist halt selber keine Naturwissenschaft. Woher kommt denn die Mathematik,
Warum sind die mathematischen Aussagen wahr? Warum können wir sie anwenden? So, also auch eine sehr grundlegende Frage, die auch nicht so einfach zu beantworten ist oder hatte ich man schon zwei,
Fragen.
Einfach zu beantworten, warum ist das nicht einfach zu beantworten?
Na ja, im Grunde muss man sich erstmal entscheiden, äh wenn man sich die Frage stellt, was die Mathematik so besonders ausmacht,
ähm entweder die Mathematik gibt es in der Welt als irgendwas, sowas ist mit Platon verbunden historisch als ähm,
irgendwie sowas, was einfach existiert, mathematische Gegenstände, so ist.
Eigenes Naturgesetz so.
Gibt's halt einfach Zahlen in der Welt und das ist eine Eigenschaft der Welt, dass zwei plus zwei, vier ist.
Aber es ist ja eine, es ist ja eine äh philosophische oder psychische Leistung des Menschen äh überhaupt erst zu sagen, dass es zwei äh gibt, weil das ja quasi die eine direkte Folge des Abstraktionsvermögens, das.
Eben. Und das wäre eben die andere Seite, also die andere mögliche Position, dass man sagt, das ist Quatsch, das ist sowas wie Mathematik in der Welt gibt. Wir können den Menschen hier nicht ausklammern. Wir müssen immer überlegen, hat das nicht doch auch, was damit zu tun, wie wir Menschen die Welt,
formieren und verstehen und insofern.
Deswegen sozusagen die Frage, kann die Mathematik wahr sein, wenn sie ja eigentlich nur eine Folge unserer selbst eingebildeten Intelligenz ist.
Genau oder so die ganz relativ handfeste Frage, wenn wir jetzt einen Alien treffen würden, würde der mit uns übereinstimmen, dass zwei plus zwei, vier ist. So, macht das überhaupt Sinn, dass wir in unsere Botschaften, an Aliens, solche arymetischen Sachen reinsch.
Überhaupt ja schon sich darauf einigen können, dass es zwei gibt.
Genau. So. Also insofern, das sind halt also das zeigt einfach diese Frage ist jetzt nicht von vornherein total offensichtlich geklärt.
Ja. Ja. Hat der hatte die Philosophie dann auch eine Antwort parat.
Die Philosophie und da kommen wir wahrscheinlich später noch drauf. Die ist einfach sehr sehr gut darin verschiedene Antwortenmöglichkeiten sehr klar zu fassen, sodass man überhaupt erstmal den Überblick bekommt in den eigenen Wirren und ungeordneten Gedanken,
Welche Optionen man hat und was für die eine oder für die andere Antwortmöglichkeit spricht und das hilft als erster Schritt denke ich schon mal ganz enorm,
um sich dann für eine Antwort zu entscheiden, aber Philosophie heißt immer erstmal.
Die richtige Frage zu finden.
Genau und die richtigen Begriffe herauszuarbeiten, die einem bei der Beantwortung dieser Frage helfen können.
Okay. Das ist so ein bisschen wie bei Perner, so richtiger Lachs ist mit der Frage nach dem Leben, dem Universum und dem ganzen Rest.
Ganz genau.
Um jetzt zu der Frage nach der Astronomie zurückzukommen ähm dann von der Mathematik war dann der nächste Schritt, aber relativ spät nach dem Abitur in die Physik, weil ich dachte, Mathematik ist toll,
Aber bestimmtes Mathematik noch toller, wenn man sie auf die Welt anwendet und dann ist man halt in der Physik.
Und dann bin ich nach Berlin gegangen, ähm habe mir erstmal ein Jahr genommen, um so ein bisschen als Mögliche auszuprobieren und habe in diesem Jahr Philosophie studiert,
hatte dann den Plan nach diesem Jahr voll und normal mit Physik anzufangen.
Dann hatte sich aber in dem Jahr herausgestellt, dass die Philosophie kein Studium ist, was man in einem Jahr mal eben so ab abhandeln kann. Nee, tatsächlich nicht, aber so naiv war ich damals nach Berlin gegangen.
War dann klar, okay, jetzt muss ich weiter studieren und habe dann einfach ein Doppelstudium angefangen. Und auch da war ich dann aber erstmal eher in der theoretischen Physik unterwegs. Also, Nägel zur Mathematik, war irgendwie naheliegend, habe dann da aber ein Professor kennengelernt.
Wir reden von der TU Berlin.
TU Berlin, genau. Also in Berlin damals ähm konnte man nur an der TU-Astronomie überhaupt machen.
Da gab's den alten Herrn Professor Siedelmaier, ein Bayer, der ähm ja, irgendwie eine ganz,
eindrucksvolle Art hat Vorlesungen zu halten. Also ist eine Vorlesung, die handelten schon von Astronomie, aber die haben so das Weltganze und alle Fragen, die man sich so als Mensch stellen kann, eigentlich immer noch mit integriert.
Wurden damals auch als Kindergottesdienste bezeichnet, die Einführungsveranstaltung, weil man da einfach nur saß und gestaunt hat. Und der hat mich sehr, sehr beeindruckt und,
hat dann auch gleichzeitig mein Interesse für die Philosophie mit aufgefangen, weil das auch Fragen waren, die ihn interessiert haben,
Und so bin ich dann langsam immer stärker in Richtung Astronomie gegangen im Studium und dann war irgendwann klar, dass ist das Fach, das ich weiter betreiben will.
Mhm. Okay und so kam's dann auch.
So kam's dann auch. Ähm erstmal dann theoretische Astrophysik, also immer noch viel programmieren und Modelle und Rechnen und so weiter. Ähm das war die Diplomarbeit. Dann habe ich ähm Doktorarbeit gemacht, allerdings nicht in Berlin, sondern in Bonn.
Und da ging's dann los.
Das dann natürlich sehr, sehr spät mit dem echten Beobachten. Also da bin ich dann nach Chile gefahren, habe da ähm mit radioastronomischen Teleskopen beobachtet und habe da dann die beobachtende Seite der Astronomie kennengelernt.
Dann bei einem der ISO-Teleskope.
Das war, das war ein kleines Teleskop, das ähm betrieben wird von den Unis Köln Bonn und ein paar japanischen ähm Universitäten.
Nicht bei der ESO aufgehangen ist.
Nee, also ein relativ kleines Projekt.
Aber schon Attackama-Wüste, da wo sie alle rumstehen.
Genau, das steht auf dem Gelände des Almer-Observatoriums. Also natürlich eine Wahnsinnskulisse und unglaublich eindrucksvoll.
Wenig Sauerstoff.
Genau das auch und das war ein Projekt, was ein so geringes Budget hatte, dass wir auch gleichzeitig unter sehr anspruchsvollen Bedingungen arbeiten mussten. Also wir hatten keinen Raum, der mit Sauerstoff angereichert war.
War alles sehr sportlich, aber natürlich für mich wahnsinnig interessant und spannend und ich hab unglaublich viel gelernt.
Ich habe gehört, man muss da richtig vorher nochmal einen Test machen, bevor man da überhaupt hingelassen wird.
Das muss man, aber das Merkwürdige ist, dass man medizinisch nicht wirklich gut vorhersagen kann, wer die Höhe gut verarbeitet und wer nicht. Also aus diesem Test kann man nicht besonders viel ableiten. Meiner Erfahrung, ja.
Und ähm also man man fährt dann einfach hoch am ersten Tag zwei Stunden und zweiten Tag vier Stunden und guckt dann immer, wie viel Sauerstoffgehalt man noch im Blut hat,
muss dann einfach sehr genau aufpassen, also wenn's dann runter geht und man sich so ein bisschen komisch fühlt, also ein bisschen komisch fühlt man sich immer, wenn man sich so ein bisschen mehr als komisch fühlt, da muss man einfach so sofort.
Wieder runterfahren, genau.
Klar. Ja. Okay. Das war bestimmt ganz bemerkenswert. Da muss ich ja dann doch nochmal fragen, wie das mit dem Sternenhimmel da unten.
Sehr gerne.
Ist schick.
Es ist sehr sehr schick. Ähm es ist, als ich meine, diese ganze Wüste ist einfach schon mal unfassbar, sieht da ja wirklich aus wie auf dem Mars mit diesem rötlichen Sand.
Wo er auch fast nichts Grünes ist. Man kann unfassbar weit gucken. Ähm.
Ja, es ist einfach für den, für die, für die Augen, für die Wahrnehmung ist es extrem ungewöhnlich. Und so noch ein paar Wochen wird's dann auch anstrengend, also ich hatte dann immer irgendwann den Punkt erreicht, wo ich mich wirklich noch was Grünem gesehen habe.
Aber ähm also die Wüste ist sehr eindrucksvoll und dann dieser Himmel, es ist erstmal interessant, wenn man von einer Nordhalbkuge kommt
man ja erstmal diese enorme Irritation, dass man dann den Südsternhimmel sieht, der ja nun mal ziemlich anders aussieht, dann die Margelanschen Wolken, was natürlich unglaublich toll ist, wo man dann fremde Galaxien bloß im Auge so deutlich sehen kann,
und die Milchstraße ist halt, also habe ich nie in dieser Schönheit ansonsten gesehen, auch wenn es natürlich in Brandenburg auch sehr schön ist, aber also, Atacama.
Malerneid auf jeden Fall,
äh gibt mir aber noch die Gelegenheit mal auf eine alte Raumzeitfolge zu verweisen, wo ich mich mit Jochen äh Liske genau über diese bodengestütze Astronomie unterhalten äh habe ähm,
Das war die Live-Raubzeit äh Ausgabe im äh das heißt Großplanetarium in äh Berlin, wo er glaube ich auch schon mal äh gewesen bist.
Ja. Gut ähm das war bestimmt äh beeindruckend. Dann ist man wahrscheinlich auch komplett verschweißt mit dem mit dem Thema, oder? Dann.
Absolut, ja. Na ja, es ist ähm also ich hatte halt das große Glück, so die verschiedenen Seiten der Astronomie kennenlernen zu dürfen, also,
Es ist ja so, dass man im Grunde zwei Communitys hat, die aber auch immer mehr zusammenwachsen. Auf der einen Seite die Theoretiker und die Modellierer und dann auf der anderen Seite die Beobachter. Die hält zwar auch natürlich Modelle benutzen, aber eigentlich so von den Teleskopen herkommen.
Und dadurch, dass ich da einmal durchs Spektrum durchgelaufen bin, also vom Computer kommt immer näher an die Teleskope gerückt bin, ähm.
Ich ja, einfach das Glück gehabt, sehr, sehr viele verschiedene Aspekte der Forschung kennenzulernen und auch selber machen zu dürfen und,
dann war ich als Postdoc in Frankreich in Grenabel, wo auch ein sehr eindrucksvolles Teleskop ist, also wiederum Interferometer, das nur immer Interferometer,
Zweitausendfünfhundert Meter Höhe eine großes Plateau in den in den Alpen, also auch ein unglaublich eindrucksvoller und schöner Ort. Und das war.
Auch so ein Aspekt an den ich als ich mich für die Astronomie entschieden habe, nie gedacht habe, dass das so ein Abenteueraspekt mit sich bringt. Weil wenn man Physik studiert, denkt man ja, man wird sein ganzes Leben irgendwo in einem unspektakulären Büro verbringen, nicht viel sehen.
Oder im Labor.
Oder im Labor und ähm ja die Astronomie ist da doch wirklich was Besonderes. Also ich meine, das ist ja jetzt auch wieder noch eine Diskussion für sich, inwiefern die Astronomen,
ein bisschen zurückschrauben sollten mit ihrer Reisetätigkeit und Servicebeobachtung werden immer stärker eingeführt aus guten Gründen, aber,
Es ist schon was, was die Astronomische Tätigkeit sehr entscheidend ausmacht, glaube ich, dass man diese.
Ähm ja erstmal sehr international denkt und dass man dann aber auch die Welt aus der Perspektive der Teleskope kennenlernt.
Ja, man muss ja auch einfach in Kontakt stehen mit äh mit mit dem was man tut so und das äh hilft natürlich an der Stelle enorm. Okay? So, das heißt äh promoviert hast du in in Bonn, wenn ich das richtig sehe, worum ging's da.
Da ging es um Stoßwellen im Interstellaren Medium Schocks wie deutsche Übersetzung ist immer so ein bisschen holprig. Ähm,
und das ist ein Thema, was ähm also was sind Schocks, Schocks,
Kennen wir von der Erde? Immer wenn irgendwas explodiert und sich dann Materie mit Überschallgeschwindigkeit ausbreitet, dann hast du eine Stoßwelle. Und das Gute an Stoßwellen ist, dass die einfach so schnell sind
dass das Medium, in das sie reinlaufen, vorher nicht gewarnt werden kann, dadurch wird die Bewegungsenergie sehr, sehr schnell in Wärme umgesetzt.
Und Dinge gehen kaputt und werden heiß und fangen an zu leuchten und das ist das, was es für die Astronomie so toll macht, denn dann sieht man was.
Und äh ich meine hier auf der Erde explodiert sehr viel im Universum ähm,
Gibt's das auch sehr häufig? Es ist insofern ein sehr universelles Phänomen. Super Nova Explosionen, sind wahrscheinlich das Beispiel, was man so als erstes im Kopf hat, aber auch wenn junge Sterne entstehen,
die sehr sehr schnelle Masseausflüsse, wieder eine blöde deutsche Übersetzung ins umgebende Medium. Ähm und insofern.
Die,
Überlegung, dass man ähm die Strahlung, die von Schocks von Stoßwellen erzeugt wird, dass man die sehr, sehr gut nutzen kann als Indikator für die physikalischen und chemischen Bedingungen, die dort, wo sie gerade entstehen, herrschen. Also man kann,
Aus den Stoßwellen sehr, sehr viel lernen über super Nova, wie schnell die sind, ähm.
Wir haben ja auch eine um unser Sonnensystem herum, oder? Diese Tim, Termination äh.
Genau. Ja, das ist auch ein Schock, ja. Also äh.
Dann der Übergang von von was von der Sonnenstrahlung zu diesem Med.
Sonnenwind, zum genau. Also das ist wie gesagt wirklich das Tolle, es gibt sie überall. Die gibt's natürlich auch in vielen verschiedenen Ausprägungen. Ich war dann ähm spezialisiert auf die Schocks in molekularen Wolken.
Die man dann vor allem eben dann benutzt, um Sternenstehung zu verstehen oder Supernova Explosion.
Also Wolken ist in Sternennebel.
Genau, also mit Gas und Staub. Mhm. Relativ dicht für kosmische Verhältnisse,
mit relativ interessanter Chemie für kosmische Verhältnisse und das war deshalb, das hatte ich ja vorhin schon erwähnt, das war eigentlich ein Thema, was ideal war, weil es auf der einen Seite eine sehr enge Anbindung an Beobachtung hat, weil man die eben überall sehen kann.
Und auf der anderen Seite sehr interessante Modellierung benötigt. Also man braucht Computermodelle, um aus dieser Strahlung irgendwas abzuleiten.
Und das habe ich dann meiner Doktorarbeit beides gemacht. Ich habe auf der einen Seite Beobachtungen genutzt und habe auf der anderen Seite ein Computermodell weiterentwickelt.
Um sozusagen das, was man beobachtet hat, auch äh kontextualisieren zu können und sagen können, das, was ich da sehe.
Hat vermutlich diesen Ursprung, weil ich habe das mal von der anderen Seite her ausgerechnet und daraus ergibt sich das so ein bisschen wie was weiß ich, äh als man jetzt Gravitationswellen entdeckt hat, hat man ja auch vorher mathematisches Modell gemacht und gesagt, ja okay, wenn da zwei schwarze Löcher zusammenballern.
Dann müsse das irgendwie so aussehen und dann macht es wupp und äh dann wurde auch das Wupp gemessen und dann wusste man halt so, okay, das.
Na ja, ich ich vergleiche das ja immer ganz gerne mit dieser Shellocoms-Methode. Wir finden als Astronom Hinweise irgendwelche Spuren im Universum. Wir können ja relativ wenig sehen. So, wir können nur das beobachten, was bei uns auf der Erde ankommt,
Ähm und das haben wir aber immerhin als ähm,
Reihe von empirischen Hinweisen, die wir verwenden können. Und dann ist die Aufgabe der Astronomen sich zu überlegen, was man daraus ableiten kann. Also Hypothesen zu entwickeln, mögliche Geschichten, physikalische Szenarien,
Dafür braucht man dann die Modelle,
Und dann ist wiederum der nächste Schritt zu sagen, okay, wenn aber das und das passiert ist, wenn die und die Bedingungen dort herrschen, dann müsste ich auch das und das sehen können. Und so geht's dann weiter, sich dann sage, okay, das überprüfe ich jetzt,
Wenn die Geschichte stimmt, die ich mir überlegt habe, dann müsste ich mit dem und dem Teleskop bei dir und den Wellenlängen auch das und das sehen. Und dann geht man dahin, überprüft es und so.
Schreitet dann ganz grob gesagt die Forschung voran. Dann merke ich vielleicht, okay, das kommt jetzt doch nicht so hin. Ich habe mir das zu einfach vorgestellt,
dann muss ich überlegen, wo könnte der Fehler stecken und so kommt man zu einem immer ja hoffentlich genaueren Bild zumindest zu einem Bild, das immer mehr empirische,
Befunde integrieren kann in ein konsistentes Bild.
Und das ist ja auch ein extrem kreativer Prozess, weil wenn man's mal umdreht, meine klassische Wahrnehmung ist ja immer so, okay, man hat man nimmt jetzt irgendeine Messung vor oder man macht
Bild äh ja aus dem Universum. Hier Habel hat wieder ein tolles, neues,
geliefert und dann staunt man da so ein bisschen äh drauf herum und sieht irgendwie ganz viele tolle Farben und viele verstehen ja schon nicht, dass
sozusagen diese Farbvielfalt im Prinzip ja schon eine Verfälschung schon eine Interpretation ist, weil man eben verschiedenste Frequenzbereiche äh die man aufgenommen hat, auch nicht unbedingt.
Einmal, sondern eben mit verschiedenen ähm Phasen oder eben auch sogar verschiedenen Teleskopen und die dann eben kombiniert, aber.
Daraus wird wirklich eine Information zu gebären.
Bedeutet ja quasi vorher schon eine Idee dafür darüber gehabt zu haben, wonach man eigentlich schauen kann und dann eben aus diesem Modell heraus rechnen zu können so okay das sind jetzt hier auch die konkreten Faktoren, die dann letzten Endes äh stattfinden müssen. Sprich,
Die eigentliche Kreativität liegt ja sozusagen da drin, sich überhaupt erstmal vorstellen zu können, was man vielleicht unter Umständen sehen könnte.
Mhm. Genau.
Und das ist ja etwas, was in der Astronomie auch nochmal anders ist als in vielen anderen physikalischen Disziplinen, dass wir dann nicht so einfach Experimente machen können. Also das ist das, was ich damit meinte, dass wir eine relativ eingeschränkte, empirische Basis haben,
Wir können halt beobachten. So wir haben vor allem elektromagnetische Strahlung. Ähm wir haben dann noch ein bisschen kosmische Teilchen, die hier ankommen.
Mhm. Aber ihr seid die einzigen mit Zeitreise, ne.
Genau, das ist dann wiederum unser guter, unser großer Vorteil,
dass wir in die Vergangenheit gucken können, ansonsten wäre es schon ja, wär's sehr, sehr schwierig, was über die Geschichte des Universums zu sagen. Aber insofern, also wir können jetzt nicht einfach, das ist immer mein Lieblingsbeispiel, wir können's nicht einfach das Magnetfeld,
In der Umgebung dieses jungen Sterns ausknipsen, weil's uns zu kompliziert ist, das zu berechnen. So es ist halt einfach da und damit müssen wir irgendwie umgehen. Und insofern ist es in der Astronomie.
Eher noch stärker der Fall, dass wir auf diese sehr komplexen Modelle angewiesen sind,
um die Interpretation dessen, was wir sehen, angemessen gestalten zu können. Also wir haben ein Problem damit, künstlich Komplexität zu reduzieren. Und das ist auf der einen Seite eine große Herausforderung, aber macht natürlich die Forschung auf der anderen Seite auch so spannend und genau wie du sagst, auch sehr kreativ.
Da kann man auch nochmal ganz kurz noch zu deinem weiteren äh Verlauf ähm.
Also im Prinzip deine Ausbildung zu dem Zeitpunkt ähm abgeschlossen gehabt, worüber wir jetzt äh gesprochen haben, beziehungsweise diese Postock äh Tätigkeit in Grenobler aufgenommen hast, was ist jetzt sozusagen dein.
Dein Fokus und wie laufen jetzt diese unterschiedlichen Disziplinen, die du äh aufgegriffen hast da zusammen.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine sehr große Frage, also die Philosophie lief ja noch parallel.
Dann weiter, so.
Genau, also die Philosophie, die lief dann noch parallel. Ich hatte da einen normalen Magisterabschluss gemacht ähm und habe dann während der Doktorarbeit.
Geguckt, was aktuell in der Wissenschaftsphilosophie gemacht wird, was irgendwie einen thematischen Anschluss hat an die astrophysikalische Forschung. Also einfach die Frage, was sagen Philosophen aktuell, mit dem ich als Astrophysikerin was anfangen kann.
Erstaunlicherweise gibt es zwar Philosophie der Physik und Philosophie der Biologie und Philosophie der Chemie,
Aber es gibt relativ oder gar zu dem Zeitpunkt relativ wenig Philosophen, die sich mit aktueller astrophysikalischer Forschung auseinandergesetzt haben. Und dann habe ich während meiner Doktorarbeit,
einfach mal thematisch geguckt, so was könnte man denn an die Astrophysik anschließen
und hab das zusammengeschrieben als ein extra Kapitel in meiner Astrophysikalischen Doktorarbeit sozusagen ein philosophisches Schlusskapitel,
und ähm habe dann versucht eine interdisziplinäre Forschungsgruppe zu etablieren, zusammen mit Philosophen und Historikern und Soziologen aus Berlin.
Das Ziel war zu verstehen,
durch die Kombination dieser verschiedenen Perspektiven, was Astrophysiker machen und wie Astrophysiker Wissen generieren.
Und erstmal war die Überlegung, na ja eine historische Perspektive ist natürlich spannend,
ist ja sowieso immer spannend zu gucken, wie hat sich die Wissenschaft entwickelt, was gab's da für Irrwege, wie entstehen Begriffe, wie ändern die sich und so weiter? Dann soziologisch ist natürlich auch interessant, weil sich da ja auch sehr, sehr viel ändert, also in der Astrophysik sehen wir ja in den letzten Jahrzehnten, wie das zu so einer,
Data Science geworden ist, aber auch die Wissenschaft großer internationaler Kollaboration. Kann man auch die Frage stellen, ändert das irgendwie die die Art von Wissen, die daraus resultiert?
Beziehungsweise überhaupt die Schaffung eigentlich dieses Fachs wissenschaft, was ja auch noch gar nicht so lange her ist.
Ja, gut. Also das natürlich auch noch, aber ja, also ich meine, da passiert natürlich immer unheimlich viel und da sind soziologische Aspekte natürlich auch einfach immer wichtig, den,
es sind ja Menschen, die die Wissenschaft machen. Dann natürlich Philosophie und die Astrophysik, also das waren unsere vier Fächer. Ähm.
Wir haben das dann auch gemacht, allerdings war das schwieriger, als ich gedacht hatte, weil in der im Zusammenkommen verschiedener Fächer einfach unglaublich viele Missverständnisse immer erstmal auftauchen. Also man muss erstmal lernen, miteinander zu reden und sich auszutauschen und,
nicht ständig aneinander vorbeizureden.
Und insofern war es für alle zwar sehr, sehr anregend, aber gleichzeitig auch zu einem gewissen Grad frustrierend, weil wir einfach nicht nicht so schnell vorangekommen sind, wie wir es gerne gewollt hätten. Und ich hab's dann einfach für mich alleine noch weiter ähm.
Weiter betrieben. Also es gab da noch andere Projekte, die parallel gelaufen sind. Aber ich habe dann sozusagen meine philosophischen Fragen mit in meinen Astrophysik Prostock genommen und habe dann von da aus vor allem auch mit Philosophen aus den USA.
Daran gearbeitet, so neue Forschungsfelder in der Wissenschaftsphilosophie aufzumachen, die interessant sein könnten.
Da ist einiges Interessantes draus entstanden, also ich hab mich dann vor allem so mit philosophischen Fragen der Modellbildung beschäftigt.
Die Kollegen in der Philosophie, die waren natürlich besonders so an kosmologischen Fragen interessiert, der aktuellen Dagmetter-Debatte und so und das habe ich dann eine Zeit lang.
Während meiner Zeit in Frankreich mitverfolgt und das läuft auch immer noch und das ist tatsächlich ein Feld, was glaube ich sehr, sehr wächst, also das Interesse, das wird eher noch größer jetzt mit der Zeit und,
ist immer mehr Austausch auch zu beobachten zwischen Astrophysikern und Philosophen. So also das war meine philosophische Geschichte sozusagen.
Dann war aber noch parallel sozusagen das dritte Standbein, das sich schon während der Doktorarbeit angefangen hatte, so ein bisschen.
Wissenschaftspublizistisch tätig zu sein. Also ich habe einen Blog für die FAZ geschrieben.
Und das ähm habe ich eigentlich während der ganzen Zeit gemacht. Also über astrophysikalische, aber auch philosophische Them.
Und dann nach meinem Post-Dog.
Ja, ist jetzt allerdings ähm also eigentlich gibt's das nicht mehr, wenn ich hätte.
Also es wird nicht mehr geführt oder es ist depubliziert worden. Man kann's noch lesen. Okay, das.
Nee, nee, man kann's noch lesen. Also es gibt es noch, es wird jetzt nicht mehr so total aktiv.
Ähm jedenfalls dann ähm war es so, dass ich nach dem ersten Postdog.
Schon eigentlich eine nächste Pustlockstelle angenommen hatte. In München wäre das gewesen, auch eine super Gruppe, tolle äh wissenschaftliche Fragestellung. Da wär's um Schocks im Kontext von Sternenstehungen gegangen,
aber dann ergab sich für mich relativ äh aus heiterem Himmel,
die Möglichkeit, mich auf eine feste Redakteurstelle bei der FAZ zu bewerben. Und das hat natürlich dann erstmal für mich zu einem riesigen inneren Dilemma geführt, weil ich eigentlich natürlich immer in der Forschung bleiben wollte und mich auch immer so gesehen habe als Astrophysikerin,
Gleichzeitig aber zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon sehr frustriert war hinsichtlich der Arbeitsbedingungen für Nachwuchswissenschaftler. Also es ist ja einfach es ist ein tolles Leben auf der einen Seite, aber auf der einen Seite dieses ständige
durch die Welt ziehen und sich nirgends so richtig angekommen fühlen und auch gar nicht zu wissen, braucht die Community mich eigentlich wirklich oder.
Oder eigentlich auch nicht. So, also das hat mich schon auch sehr belastet. Und,
Insofern war dann die Frage, bleibe ich in der Wissenschaft und versuche meinen Platz dort zu finden.
Was auch noch bei mir zusätzlich dadurch erschwert wurde, dass diese dieses interdisziplinäre Interesse jetzt auch nicht wirklich was ist, was so richtig in die Wissenschaft reinpasst. Also man hat ja eigentlich oder zumindest wird's immer gesagt, man braucht halt so ein ganz straighten, sauberen Lebenslauf.
Dann gibt's auch einen Nobelpreis irgendwann. Genau. Mhm.
Den wollen wir ja. Also jedenfalls für Philosophie war da jetzt nicht so total offensichtlich Platz. Ich hab's natürlich trotzdem immer gemacht, aber war dann sehr frustriert über jede Äußerung von Unverständnis aus meinem direkten Umfeld.
Weil ich dann dachte, okay, vielleicht ist es dann doch ist die Wissenschaft heute doch zu eng geworden. So, das waren damals meine Gedanken. So und dann kamen halt plötzlich dieses Stellenangebot von der Zeitung von der FAZ, wo ich wusste, die finden das eher gut, wenn ich mich für viele andere Dinge auch interessiere,
dann eine feste Stelle, nicht diese Befristung und endlich mal irgendwo ankommen. So und das waren, glaube ich, so zwei Wochen quasi ohne Schlaf, wo ich, ey, ich dachte, oh mein Gott, ich kann mich da nie entscheiden, was soll ich machen? Und dann habe ich mich aber für die Zeitung entschieden und seitdem also seit Anfang zweitausendsiebzehn,
bin ich jetzt hauptberuflich Wissenschaftsjournalistin, also schreibe über Astrophysik, aber auch alle möglichen anderen Themen,
macht es jetzt noch so ein bisschen nebenher mit der Forschung. Also ich habe noch philosophische Artikel publiziert, habe jetzt gerade letzte Woche Bescheid bekommen, dass mein letztes PayPal aus Conover angenommen wurde,
ist natürlich total schwierig, das neben so einem Job zu machen, aber so ein bisschen habe ich da zumindest noch Anknüpfungspunkte,
und ähm ja, also insofern habe ich's jetzt bisher noch nicht bereut, aber dadurch ist jetzt mein Lebensweg noch untypischer geworden, wenn man so will.
Na ja, untypischer Lebensweg ist ja eigentlich was sehr erstrebenswertes. Ja dann.
Versuchen wir nochmal so ein bisschen reinzugehen in in so diese ganzen Fragestellungen, die dich äh umtreiben oder sagen wir mal, vielleicht die die Wissenschaft auch an sich äh umtreiben. Und jetzt hat's ja schon diese Forschungskollaporation angesprochen, ne, Philosophen, Historiker, Soziologen, et cetera.
Greif ich mir mal so die Historiker raus, weil ich finde das immer ganz interessant, so ein bisschen mal herzuleiten, wo kommt's denn eigentlich alles her, denn im Prinzip ist ja eigentlich der Blick aufs Universum von Anfang an.
Eine philosophische Frage gewesen. Dieses wo sind wir? Was sind wir? Worin sind wir, sind wir, sind wir die Mitte, sind wir irgendwie in irgendeinem,
völlig uninteressanten Teil des ganzen äh kann man das überhaupt so sehen? Ist das unendlich? Was bedeutet das, wenn dem so ist, et cetera, also es ist ja einfach etwas, was die Menschheit schon
glaube ich so ab dem Moment, wo das mit dem zwei plus zwei gleich vier.
Furchtbar.
Durch war, war das dann sozusagen die nächste Frage. Zumindest denke ich mal, hat sich's jetzt nicht so.
Beschäftigt, was weiß ich schon. Ähm wo muss man da hinschauen? Also mir würde natürlich so die Antike als erstes einfallen, die ja eigentlich so,
die ganzen großen Fragen gerollt haben und im Prinzip ist ja auch ein bisschen die Geburtsstunde der der Philosophie, oder?
Mhm. Absolut, das hat Aristut es mal sehr schön gefasst, dass.
Der Blick in den Sternenhimmel und das Staunen, was ich aus diesem Blick ergibt,
Der Anfangspunkt ist für die Neugier des Menschen und damit dann für die Philosophie und auch für die Wissenschaften.
Also das war damals schon klar der Blick in den Himmel, das ist so der Startpunkt für die ganzen Reflektierenden Fragen
genau wie du gesagt hast für die Frage nach unserem eigenen Standpunkt und nach dem großen Weltganzen. Und insofern ist es wirklich auch schön diese alten Schriften zu lesen, das sind ganz ganz hübsche Zitate, die sich mit dem Sternenhimmel auch beschäftigen
Mark Auriel habe ich neulich mal gefunden, das muss ich mal ganz kurz hier nachschlagen, denn das ist ein,
Wunderschöner Satz, an den ich jetzt auch ein paar Mal in der Korunakrise gedacht habe. Er schrieb äh Blicke oft zu den Sternen impor, als wandeltest du mit ihnen. Solche Gedanken reinigen die Seele von dem Schmutz des Erdenlebens.
Und das finde ich ist genau das, also ich habe das so nachgefühlt, dass sowieso schon immer, aber in diesem Jahr ganz besonders, wo wir sehr viel Schmutz des Erdenlebens um uns rum hatten. Ähm ich finde es schon, dass die astronomischen Fragen der Blick in den Sternenhimmel,
reinigende Wirkung hat und ich glaube, das ist das, was auch so viele Menschen,
egal wie intellektuell oder akademisch sie sonst so aufgestellt sind, was sie dann doch auch immer wieder zum Sternenhimmel treibt und was diese unglaubliche Wirkung dieses Blicks ausmacht.
Ist ja auch das, was die Astronauten alle berichten, sodass diese Perspektive von außen ihnen irgendwie so eine
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich's nennen soll. Also äh einerseits so so eine so eine universelle Friedfertigkeit äh zu injizieren scheint, so, also da ist so wie so jede Grenze, jedes Auftrennung, da gibt's einfach nur noch Erde und Menschheit äh
so als äh kleine Untergruppe und,
Der Rest des Universums. Auf einmal werden diese ganzen Probleme so unglaublich unwichtig und man hört auch immer wieder raus, wie wie auch diese ganze
Diese Fragen internationaler Kooperation einfach total selbstverständlich sind dann auf einmal.
Genau. Na ja und ich meine, das ist natürlich das eine, also diese unglaubliche Wirkung des Nachthimmels, aber dann der Versuch der Griechen, ich meine, mag Auri war jetzt kein Grieche, sondern Römer, aber ähm.
Genau. Dieser antiken und alten Denker. Ähm dann natürlich dann der versuchte sich dann daraus ergibt,
das Welt ganze rational zu verstehen und abzuleiten
wie das alles irgendwie einen Sinn ergeben kann, in dem wir uns als Menschen einfügen. Und das hat damals natürlich angefangen, das ist äh unglaublich, was sie damals schon für Theorien entwickelt haben, ohne diese ganzen empirischen Möglichkeiten zu haben, die sich ja erst relativ ähm
kürzlich ergeben haben. Und wenn man dann,
durch die Geschichte hindurch guckt, wie sich's wie das halt sich so als roter Faden entwickelt hat. Also die Astronomie als älteste Wissenschaft, die wir besitzen, die einfach immer ein Thema war und über die allermeiste Zeit dann natürlich auch ein philosophisches Thema war,
eben, weil man ja im Bezug auf den Gesamtkosmos ganz, ganz schwer nur an empirische Daten kommt,
Und das aber natürlich gleichzeitig diese diese sehr, sehr drängende Frage ist, was sich dort befindet und was das für uns heißt. Und ähm,
Also insofern ist die Philosophie historisch natürlich ein ganz zentraler Bestandteil der Astronomie und des Blicks in den Himmel.
Was haben denn die Griechen sich so gefragt? Und was haben die Sinn für Antworten gefunden darauf.
Ja, da muss ich jetzt gleich mal als Disclaimer sagen, ich bin wirklich da keine Expertin für Antike Philosophie, sondern eher für die moderne Philosophie, aber ich meine, dass.
Ja, wir kommen da ja auch hin, aber so grundsätzlich, was was.
Ja, also zum Beispiel.
Um die aktuelle Zeit zu verstehen. Also ich meine, die haben das mit dem Atom äh sozusagen sich erdacht und dass die Erde rund ist und so.
Was sind so die letzten Bestandteile von allem für irgendwie naheliegende Frage, so man kann alles immer kleiner machen, ist da irgendwann ein Ende und wenn ja, wie sieht das aus? So die geometrischen Überlegungen, die dann da einfließen, wieder irgendwie auch einen Rückbezug zu unseren mathematischen Fragen vom Anfang,
ähm dann aber auch, ich meine bei Aristoteles zum Beispiel, der hatte ja ein Weltbild, was sehr stark von Zwecken bestimmt war, also ein theologisches Weltbild, wo er nicht wie wir das heute machen, so von den Anfangsbedingungen her, sich die Dinge angeguckt hat, also man.
Setzt irgendwas in Bewegung und das ist bestimmt durch die Anfangsbedingungen und die Gesetze, die wirken, sondern bei Aristotelis, die umgekehrte Sichtweise, wo will etwas hin,
Also vom Ziel her gedacht, was ja auch schon mal interessant ist, also für uns vielleicht ein bisschen abwegig an manchen Stellen, aber,
Interessant ist es halt eigentlich schon auch ein sehr gleichwertiges Erklärungskonzept, ist auch wenn's genau andersrum ist als wie wir uns das heute denken. Und dann,
von daher dann die Überlegung, okay, die Erde ist im Mittelpunkt dahin strebt alles, also die Dinge fallen nach unten, weil sie zum Erdmittelpunkt wollen.
Äh
Und dann die Frage gilt das denn überall, damit dann in verschiedenen Sphären, dass er sich überlegt, ja wir haben da verschiedene Sphären, also das ähm Sublunare und das Translunare dann die verschiedenen ähm,
die er einführt
Da ist ja dann auch ganz viel, das ist natürlich total spannend, ein Bezug dann auch wiederum zur Musik, wo die Harmonienlehre eine große Rolle spielt, wo der Kosmos sehr, sehr stark mit Klängen auch assoziiert ist, also mit harmonischen Verhältnissen
Also ganz interessant und das ist das, was du auch vorhin schon meintest, was das dann auch für uns wiederum so interessant macht jetzt unabhängig vom historischen Wert
man sich überlegen kann, haben diese Ideen vielleicht auch doch eine Wirkung auf die Art von Wissenschaft, wie wir sie heute betreiben,
oder auf die Art, wie wir heute den Kosmos wahrnehmen. Und ich meine, so diese,
diese Schwingung zum Beispiel, das ist ja was, was man auch heute noch in der Kosmologie an vielen Stellen findet, also jetzt ganz offensichtlich Stream-Theorie,
mit den schwingenden Grundbausteinen. Ähm aber es sind so Gedanken und Denkfiguren, die sich wirklich über Jahrtausende durch das menschliche Denken hindurchziehen. Und die man, glaube ich, schon kennen und verstehen muss, um,
Unser heutiges Wissen in seiner gesamten Dimension, also vor dem Hintergrund all dessen, worauf es aufbaut, auch verstehen zu können.
Meine bemerkenswert war ja auch, dass die Gerichte sicher jetzt nicht nur Gedanken gemacht haben, sondern sie haben ja auch klare Erkenntnisse geschaffen. Also es war ja sozusagen auch wirklich Wissenschaft.
Das war ja gleichzeitig sozusagen vielleicht der Beginn einer Philosophie, aber es war auch gleichzeitig der Beginn einer Wissenschaft, wie wir,
sie heute natürlich sie anders, aber so also dieses Beispiel mit okay wir verstehen jetzt einfach auch mal die Welt einen konkreten Beobachtungen, wir überprüfen das daran und dass dann so die Basis für unseren nächsten Gedankenschritt so.
Ja, aber das ist eben gerade eine ganz interessante Frage,
weil man als Physiker immer dazu neigt, das genauso zu sehen, dass wir so eine lineare Erfolgsgeschichte in der Geschichte ablesen können. Also damals hatten die schon die richtige Idee, die Griechen hatten halt nicht so richtig tolle Experimente und so, aber so für ihre Möglichkeiten haben sie es ganz gut gemacht.
Etwas arrogante Sichtweise aus der heutigen Perspektive, die aber von den Philosophen nicht geteilt werden würde, denn die würden sehr, sehr viel stärker sagen, na ja, damals war das,
will einfach so ein anderes in einer mythologischen Welt, wo auch Götter eine wichtige Rolle gespielt haben, wo einfach die Bedeutungsebenen von allen Phänomenen in der Welt so eine völlig andere waren als heute,
dass wir das so einfach gar nicht sagen können. Also wir können uns zwar die Elemente rauspicken, die uns heute sinnvoll erscheinen, aber das würde denen nicht unbedingt ähm gerecht werden.
Bis nicht gesamtgesellschaftlich gerecht werden.
Mir aber auch vom Denken her nicht unbedingt, denn ähm also wenn man sich jetzt zum Beispiel Aristotelis nimmt,
es ist eine andere Art auf die Welt zu schauen. Wenn man von ihnen Zwecken her denkt,
als die Art, wie wir auf dem Pendel oder auf irgendwas gucken, was auf die Erde fällt. Und da würde man als Philosoph sagen,
das kann man nicht so einfach wegabstrahieren. Und insofern stimmt es schon, dass die vieles ähm.
Entdeckt und gefunden haben, wo wir heute sagen, ja Wahnsinn, dass sie das damals rausgefunden haben, also gerade so mit Himmelsmechanik, ähm so ein Finsternis Mondfinsternis, diese ganzen Sachen ist ja unglaublich, dass die das damals schon,
sind natürlich nicht alle, aber dass es da überhaupt Leute gab, die eine Idee hatten, was da passiert.
Oder auch nicht nur in Griechenland auch in Ägypten. Also.
Genau. Würde man ja denken, ist unfassbar, würden wir wahrscheinlich heute nicht unbedingt so hinbekommen. Ähm aber man,
Eigentlich darf man es nicht von dem Gesamtdenkgebäude extrahieren, was ansonsten so die Zeit geprägt hat und ähm das ist halt was, wofür man, glaube ich, sensibel wird, wenn man Philosophie studiert hat.
Gerade in der Wissenschaftstheorie immer einen sehr, sehr starken historischen Anteil hat. Ähm weil man.
Da sieht das eben so Sachen wie ein Weltbild doch auch eine große Rolle spielen. Und das ist dann was, aber da können wir vielleicht auch später noch drauf, was.
Für mich so die Kernfrage der philosophischen Perspektive auf Wissenschaft ausmacht.
Wenn man an der Stelle nicht aufpasst, dann ist man ziemlich schnell in so einem Relativismus, dass man sagt, na ja, jede Zeit hat so ihr Weltbild und hat dann das eigene Wissen, das funktioniert dann, aber eine andere Zeit hat ein anderes Wissen. So letztendlich geht halt alles irgendwie,
Und das ist aber ja offensichtlich was, was nicht so richtig zutrifft auf unsere Welt. So, da also man würde jetzt ja nicht.
Sagen, die Griechen wussten damals mehr als ihr. Würde uns irgendwie wieder streben letztendlich oder wenn man, wenn man jetzt irgendwie,
sehr offensichtliches Argument bräuchte, würde man sagen, naja schon allein unsere Technologie zeigt ja, dass es nicht alles falsch sein kann, was wir uns so denken. So also so einfach ist es nicht, dass man sagt, alles ist relativ, aber gleichzeitig muss man schon sagen,
Es ist ein wichtiger Aspekt, dass die Menschen mit ihren Praktiken und ihren Gedanken und ihren Weltbildern doch auch eine wichtige Rolle spielen.
Zwischen diesen beiden Extremen eines Relativismus und eines Positivismus, der sagt, da ist die Welt.
So als objektiv gegebenes und da sind wir und wir versuchen uns davon einfach ein Bild zu machen und die Theorien werden immer wahrer und immer besser. Also zwischen diesen Polen irgendwie ein differenziertes, eine differenzierte Position zu entwickeln,
Das ist glaube ich heute eine Kernherausforderung.
Ja, nicht nur der Philosophie, sondern ich glaube auch der Wissenschaftler, denn das ist ein Grundproblem, was dann, was wir heute überall sehen, wenn Wissenschaft kommuniziert wird.
Nachdem so die Antike äh ein bisschen durchgerockt war,
war das ja dann so mit dem Weltbild und mit der Wissenschaft war das ja eigentlich eher so ein Fight, also zumindest in Europa äh lief's ja dann erstmal eine ganze Weile lang nicht so gut, weil die Kirche da so ihre äh Bedenken hatte, was denn da alles so aufgedeckt wird und das passiert ja dann nicht mehr so zu ihren
Märchen, die sie da äh regelmäßig erzählt haben dann.
Versuche jetzt gerade mal so ein bisschen durch irgendeine Wissenschaftsgeschichte durchzumarschieren, die ich gar nicht so gut drauf habe. Ist nur so ein bisschen so meine persönliche Wahrnehmung.
Dass es dann halt irgendwie vor hundert, zweihundert Jahren dann in so eine Phase gemündet ist, wo es dann eben
so dass andere Extreme hatte. Man da marschierte man einfach dann durch,
durch durch dieses von neuen Entdeckungen, Beweisen, neuen Formeln, die alle aufeinander aufsetzten, alle zehn, zwanzig Jahre gab's wieder irgendeinen Durchbruch.
Gut halt auch manchmal ein bisschen länger gedauert, aber auf jeden Fall war da so eine so eine kontinuierliche Beschleunigung, die dann so äh letzte Jahrhundert äh wenn da also neunzehnhundert dann irgendwie mit mit Einstein dann sozusagen zu seiner Vollexplosion kam
so, also wo dann wirklich auch eher so ein, so ein, jetzt wissen wir alles und äh was wir noch nicht wissen, dass das wissen wir aber bald und äh alles wird beherrschbar und
wo wo sozusagen der der Wissenschaft ja auch so ein so ein Mythos, der ähm,
Lösung aller Probleme so ein bisschen zugeteilt wurde. Kann man sich vielleicht heute überhaupt gar nicht mehr so richtig vorstellen, was ja eben,
diese ganzen Erkenntnisse auch ausgelöst haben, also dass dass die Erfindung von der Nutzung von von Strom und und Gas und vielen anderen Phänomenen vor allem natürlich auch Strom.
Die Gesellschaften ja bin von wenigen Jahrzehnten komplett auf den Kopf gestellt hat, nicht immer unbedingt zum Guten, aber eben auf einmal waren Sachen halt möglich
die vorher undenkbar waren. Auch der medizinische Fortschritt hat natürlich da äh erhebliche ähm erheblichen Beitrag dazu geleistet.
Ähm da war dann sozusagen die Wissenschaft auf einmal das neue Weltbild, das ist das ist jetzt wo meine Wahrnehmung, würdest du.
Absolut. Also das schließt auch ziemlich genau an das an, was ich jetzt gerade ähm was ich gerade versucht habe zu motivieren, denn das.
War diese extreme, dieser extreme Wissenschaftsoptimismus,
der sich auch in der Philosophie wiederfindet aus der Zeit, also logischer Positivismus, logischer Empirismus wo es eigentlich dann vor allem darum ging zu beschreiben, warum ist die Wissenschaft eigentlich so ein tolles System? Jetzt mach ich sehr vereinfacht gesagt. Aber wie macht das die Wissenschaft, dass sie,
Erkenntnisse produziert, die die Welt wiedergibt und wo es dann darum ging, was ist eine wissenschaftliche Theorie, wie kann ich wissenschaftliche,
Sätze, wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse von nichtwissenschaftlichem Abgrenzen, ähm Popper ist ja nun der Wissenschaftsphilosoph, der wahrscheinlich am allerbekanntesten ist, den kennt ja wirklich jeder und das ist ja auch was, wo
mit man alte Wissenschaftsfreund ganz gut leben kann, so mit diesem Bild. Wir haben Theorie, wir machen Experiment.
Wir gucken, was rauskommt und dann ist die Theorie falsifiziert oder auch nicht, wenn sie nicht versiffiziert ist, dann überlege ich mir einen neuen Test. Ähm.
Das lässt aber viele Aspekte erstmal außen vor, von denen ich ja gerade ähm,
behauptet habe, dass sie doch auch eine Rolle spielen. Also so Dinge wie so der der Wissenschaftler als Mensch, was hat der für eine.
Ähm Kontextualisierung, also in was für einem Weltbild befindet er sich? Wie guckt der auf die Welt? Hat das vielleicht auch einen Einfluss darauf, was er so findet? Und das war dann in der Wissenschaftsphilosophie so die Entwicklung, wie es dann weiterging nach Popa und Co.
Dass das viel, viel stärker in den Fokus gerückt wurde, also einfach indem man.
Gesagt hat, na ja, schon alleine was wir sehen, mit unserer menschlichen Wahrnehmung, das hat ganz viel auch mit Erwartungen zu tun,
mit einer Ausbildung zum Beispiel, also man, wenn man Physik studiert, man merkt's ja, man sieht die Dinge einfach ganz anders,
man sieht plötzlich Dinge, die man vorher nicht gesehen hat. Aber vielleicht sieht man auch Dinge nicht mehr, die man vorher gesehen hätte, als wenn man sich mal so wissenschaftliche Abbildungen oder so vorstellt,
Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, was heißt das dann wiederum für Wissenschaft? Und Wissenschaftshistorisch gibt's natürlich auch viele Beispiele, wo man dann sagen würde, also auch in der Astronomie,
ähm dass eine erwartungshaltung den historischen Fortschritt dann schon auch ziemlich gehemmt hat, also wo Leute irgendwas gesehen haben, aber gedacht haben, das kann nicht sein,
dem dann nicht weiter nachgegangen sind. Also zum Beispiel Entdeckung von Polsaren, äh Joselin Bell erzählt es selber immer wieder gerne die Geschichte, sie ist zwar die Entdeckerin der Pulsare. Das war ja diese Geschichte, so sie als Doktorantin.
Den Nobelpreis dafür bekommen.
Ja, das ist nochmal ein anderes Problem,
aber sie erzählt, dass ähm sich in den Jahren nach ihrer Entdeckung immer wieder bei ihr Leute gemeldet haben, die gesagt haben, ja das haben sie eigentlich auch schon beobachtet.
Ähm aber sie haben gedacht, das kann nicht sein oder es ist ein technischer Fehler oder das Instrument spinnt,
Aber tatsächlich muss es ein Pulsar gewesen sein. Und das sind natürlich auch Dinge, die irgendwie eine Relevanz besitzen, die aber so in diesem ganz sauberen auf Logik beruhenden Bild von Wissenschaft,
schwer zu integrieren sind. Und dass wir in der Wissenschaftsphilosophie dann die,
die Richtung, dass man darauf mehr geguckt hat. Also Anfang des vergangenen Jahrhunderts, Vordenker, Ludwig Flex, das war ein polnischer Arzt.
Aus der Medizin kommt ähm schon sehr stark beschrieben und thematisiert,
Ich meine, Medizin ist natürlich auch eine Wissenschaft, wo es natürlich total drauf ankommt, was man was man wie interpretiert, wo vieles unklar ist ähm,
was nicht diese diese ich sage mal Sauberkeit der Physik besitzt. Insofern liegt es vielleicht nahe dann ein bisschen,
genauer zu fragen, inwiefern hat der Forscher mit seinem blickenden Einfluss? Äh Ludwig Fleck hatte leider überhaupt gar keinen,
äh Einfluss selber, kein kein Erfolg, der ist dann in den Wirrungen der Geschichte. Als polnischer Jude untergegangen, ähm, aber dann in den sechziger Jahren,
Thomas Kuhn die Gedanken nochmal aufgegriffen und ausgearbeitet,
in seinem Buch die strukturwissenschaftliche Revolution und das war dann eines der einflussreichsten wissenschaftsphilosophischen Werke des vergangenen Jahrhunderts.
Und da ist äh die These, dass es eben kein linearen, wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt gibt, sondern dass man immer zwischendrin Revolutionen hat.
Die alles umschmeißen, alle Denkmodelle, alle Begriffe und dass man insofern gar nicht sagen kann,
wie sich die Wissenschaft vor der Revolution zu der Wissenschaft nach der Revolution vergleicht. Äh also ob sie besser ist oder schlechter, einfach weil sich die gesamten.
Ähm enormativen Systeme verändert haben. Also du hast keinen gemeinsamen Rahmen mehr, um den Vergleich vorzunehmen. Und das ist natürlich eine total radikale These, die Wissenschaftler nicht unbedingt gefällt, die aber sehr, sehr viele Diskussionen ausgelöst hat.
Und dann in verschiedene Richtungen noch weiter verfolgt wurde, also in die noch radikalere Richtung. Thomas Kuhn, selbst Physiker war eigentlich gar nicht so radikal,
viel der Radikalität seiner Thesen dann nochmal zurückgenommen nachträglich aber,
hatte damit sozusagen Tür und Tor geöffnet zu so einer Haltung zu sagen, na ja, Wissenschaftler sind halt auch nur abgerichtete Musterseher.
So und was sie sehen, hängt halt von so vielen Faktoren ab, dass da die wirkliche Welt ziemlich weit zurücktritt,
und das ähm hat natürlich dann die Wissenschaftsphilosophie sehr, sehr weit entfernt von den Wissenschaftlern, die gesagt haben, ja,
Markt zwar auf irgendeine Art plusive klingen, aber es kann überhaupt nicht das beschreiben, was wir in unserem Alltag machen und guckt euch mal die Technologie an, die spricht ja auch dagegen, das ist alles völlig relativ ist.
Wir sind wo jetzt im Zeitstrahl, also sind wir jetzt schon sozusagen in der aktuellen Zeit angekommen oder bewegen wir uns gerade noch.
Genau, das ist so die zweite Hälfte des vergangenen Jahrhunderts. Also Thomas Kuhn zweiundsechzig und.
Dann waren das so die Reaktionen auf sein Buch, was sehr, sehr viel Resonanz hervorgerufen hat. Und jetzt mittlerweile sind wir aber in noch einer neuen Phase in der Wissenschaftsphilosophie, wo sich die Philosophen weitestgehend wieder sehr stark den Wissenschaftlern angenähert haben,
und nicht mehr so radikal sind wie früher, sondern vielmehr sagen, na ja, man muss das alles einfach sehr viel,
genauer und differenzierter anschauen ähm wo es auch gar nicht mehr so die Wissenschaftstheorie,
gibt, also wo wirklich selten der wissenschaftliche Fortschritt an sich beschrieben wird, sondern wo es dann eher um so Fragen geht, was machen eigentlich Biologen? Was haben die für Probleme, die zum Beispiel Physiker nicht haben.
Oder unterscheidet sich das Vorgehen von Astrophysikern grundsätzlich von dem, von anderen Physikern.
Was für eine Art Probleme sind da jetzt mit gemeint? Also was haben die, also Probleme.
Probleme haben wir ja alle. Erstmal den Biol.
Philosophische Probleme sozusagen.
Ja, also bei den Biologen zum Beispiel ist natürlich ein Problem, was auch ähm sehr dauerhaft angelegt ist. Die Frage, was ist Leben? Und das ist natürlich eine philosophische Frage.
Kann man, kann man so ein Rudelbiologen bei einer Party gut in Betrieb halten, wenn.
Am Leben oder nicht.
Genau. Aber auch im Prinzip kann man, glaube ich, auch die Astrophysiker auf den Partys gut am Leben halten, indem man indem man sich fragt, was sie noch als Leben zählen würden, wenn sie das irgendwo auf einem fremden Planeten entdecken würden oder nicht. Also ich meine, das sind ja dann auch Fragen, die uns.
Astrobiologen mit umtreiben. Oder andere interessante Frage in der Biologie wäre äh in der Biologie redet man ja sehr oft von Funktionen. So die Funktion des Herzens ist es, den Körper mit Sauerstoff zu versorgen.
Aber Funktion ist ja erstmal eine komische Geschichte. So das ist ja nichts, was in der Welt so direkt existiert. Also man kann am Herz die Funktion nicht ablesen. Das ist eine Interpretation. Das ist dann wiederum.
Auch eine Beobachtung, also.
Ja, aber wie wird eine Funktion definiert? Also wenn ich irgendwas baue, zum Beispiel ist es klar, wenn ähm du jetzt deinen Rechner so eingerichtet hast.
Dann hast du ihm diese Funktion gegeben in diesem Kontext. So kommt die Funktion von dir.
Ich beobachte dich, ich nehme an, das Ding hat eine bestimmte Funktion, kann dich dann fragen, bin ich damit, liege ich damit richtig? Mit.
Dieser Interpretation oder eben nicht. So, aber bei natürlichen Organen oder was auch immer ist es halt nicht so ganz klar. So wir überlegen uns schon, was das für eine Funktion hat.
Aber wie wurde die Funktion wirklich festgelegt? Können wir uns vielleicht irren? Also das Grundproblem ist einfach ausgedrückt, Funktion hat immer sehr viel mit Interpretation zu tun und man würde aber sagen, die Welt ohne uns Menschen hat sowas wie interpretation und nicht.
Ich meine die Fähigkeit des Menschen mit der Natur so umzugehen, wie wir es eben
tun, basiert ja auf dieser Abstraktionsmöglichkeit und das bedeutet ja letzten Endes auch äh der Findung einer Sprache. Und ich habe so ein bisschen so den Eindruck, dass die philosophische Hinterfragung von Wissenschaft eben vor allem eine Frage nach der richtigen
Sprache ist, also wenn du sagst, was ist die Funktion? Dann ist das ja äh im Prinzip auch erstmal so ein Begriffskampf so, ne.
Na ja, aber es geht halt erstmal darum, was die Funktion als Funktion ist. Also jetzt gar nicht so rum so die Frage, wie definiere ich sie? Es war, also um jetzt mal einen schlimmen Begriff aus der Philosophie zu nutzen, es wäre eine ontologische Frage nach der Seinsform.
Das meine ich auch, also sozusagen was heißt Funktion so, ja.
Ja, aber das wäre halt dann, also Sprache wäre ja wie, wie nutzen wir dieses diesen Begriff? Also das, das gibt's natürlich auch als philosophische Herangehensweise, da dann bist du halt ein Sprachphilosoph, der sich,
der die These vertritt, dass man eigentlich fast alles über die Welt daraus lernen kann, wie wir über sie sprechen.
Musst du aber nicht sein. Du kannst auch ähm wieder Physiker sein oder physikalist. Und wenn du Physikalist bist und sagst, sagst, ähm.
Was ist denn ein Physikalist.
Ja, der Physikalist würde sagen ähm in der Welt gibt es physikalische Vorgänge und wenn ich mir das angucke, dann bin ich sozusagen safe, dann brauche ich nicht viel mehr.
Okay, das ist ja meine interessante Berufsbezeichn.
Also jedenfalls insofern ist es nicht nur Sprache, ähm es ist auch viel Sprache in der modernen Philosophie und das ist glaube ich auch das, was die Philosophie für die Wissenschaftler.
Sehr ähm nützlich macht, dass die Philosophen Meister darin sind, Begriffe scharf zu definieren und logisch konsistent einzusetzen.
Also wir haben ein sehr sehr scharf gespitztes begriffliches Werkzeugset,
man als Wissenschaftler natürlich auch sehr sehr gut benutzen kann. Man muss das ja nicht alles neu erfinden, auch wenn man das als Wissenschaftler oftmals gerne macht,
aber es gibt natürlich auch dann Fragen, die sich nochmal jenseits der Sprache aufhalten. Also wenn man jetzt nochmal ähm wissenschaftliche Beispiele sucht, zu fragen, wie,
Was ist der Status der Raumzeit? Ähm,
Wir haben ja dann schon wieder fast bei solchen griechischen Fragen, was ist das, was dem allen zugrunde liegt, kann man sagen, dass Felder fundamental ist und als Teilchen oder andersrum, sowas halt. Und das ist dann relativ unabhängig von Sprache, sondern das sind dann wirklich orthologische Fragen, die nach der Seins Beschaffenheit unserer Welt fragen.
Genau, Designsbeschaffung halt unserer äh Welt. Vielleicht ist es an der Stelle mal ganz äh hilfreich, auch mal so einen Blick darauf zu werfen,
was eigentlich unser aktuelles Bild vom Universum ist und wo eigentlich gerade so diese nicht physikalischen, sondern die philosophischen Bruchstellen äh stattfinden. Oder ob's,
eigentlich für philosophische Bruchstellen sind, also im Wesentlichen reden wir ja sozusagen von von der Grenze des des Non und des,
was ja wie wir äh alle gelernt haben, auch noch verschiedene Ausprägungen hat, so dass das Nowen annown und das so, also diese ganzen Steigerungen von äh Unwissen, da scheint's ja immer genug von zu geben,
die Frage führt auf jeden Fall zu weit, aber ich muss sie halt trotzdem stellen so. Also was, was ist denn sozusagen unser aktuelles.
Ja, schöne Frage.
Folgen, einundneunzig bis hundert vollmachen.
Ja genau, also wir haben ja hier viel darüber.
Aber ist ja offensichtlich, es gibt ja so ein paar ganz naheliegende Fragen, die schon tausend Mal besprochen wurden, die hier auch äh genug der Energie, was äh die äh Expansion des Universums.
Genau, das ist Pension. Kann man ja relativ schnell dann tatsächlich beantworten. Wir haben halt ein Standardmodell in der Kosmologie. Lambda Kult Dark Metter, was ähm auf der Grundlage.
Was bezeichnet diese drei.
Genau, also erstmal kurz es ist halt gestützt durch wahnsinnig viele Beobachtungen aus den letzten Jahrzehnten. Es ist ja alles relativ neu,
das Wissen, weil es sehr lange gedauert hat, bis wir Menschen überhaupt in der Lage waren, all diese Daten zu sammeln. So, aber jetzt seit ein paar Jahrzehnten funktioniert's halt und das ist unglaublich, dass wir das alles in einem,
relativ gut funktionierendes, kosmologisches Modell transferieren konnten. Ähm Lambakulta, Meta heißt so, weil es weil dieses kosmologische Standardmodell verschiedene,
Bestandteile hat. Also erstmal die Idee ist, es gab einen Urknall. Vor dreizehn Komma acht Milliarden Jahren. Seitdem dehnt sich das Universum aus. Äh am Anfang hat sich's kurzzeitig sehr schnell ausgedehnt in dieser Inflationsphase, die man auch nicht so richtig versteht, die aber sehr viel,
Sinn ergibt aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Und ja, also seitdem dehnt sie sich immer weiter aus. Es haben's die ersten Sterne und Galaxien gebildet und das kann man alles wunderbar durchrechnen und dann kommt man genau daraus, wo man hin möchte, vor dem Hintergrund der Beobachtung, die man gemacht hat.
Vor allem auch erstmal die ganzen Elemente äh überhaupt.
Genau, das passt alles total gut mit dem zusammen, was wir beobachten. Das einzige Problem, der einzige Schönheitsfehler ist, dass dieses Modell,
zwei, mindestens zwei, aber zwei sehr dominante Bestandteile enthält,
die wir bisher noch nicht wirklich verstehen. Und das ist ähm das Landa aus dem Namen, das ist die dunkle Energie. Also das, was hinter der beschleunigten Ausdehnung steckt. Also der.
Man beobachtet, dass das Universum sich einerseits ausdehnt, aber dabei auch immer sich schneller.
Schneller ausdehnen.
Nobelpreis zweitausendelf. Brian Schmitz soll Permutter und Adam Rees. Ähm also auch relativ neu. Diese Beobachtung des äh entsprechenden Forschungsprojektes wurde.
In den Neunzigern.
Adam Riese, das ist.
Genau. Ähm also das das ist ein Ergebnis, was in den späten Neunzigern überhaupt erst veröffentlicht wurde. Also wirklich ziemlich neues Wissen. Und es war total unerwartet, weil man dachte, das Universum, dass dessen aus,
Dehnung wird sich irgendwann wieder abbremsen, weil ja die Gravitation einfach wirksam ist. Also die ganze Materie im Universum wird das Universum irgendwann wieder zusammenziehen. Das hatte man erwartet, aber das Gegenteil ist der Fall.
Bisschen so wie so ein Steinwurf nach oben so, ja okay, geht immer weiter weg, aber wird schon irgendwann mal aufhören und wieder zurückkommen. Sieht nicht so aus, als ob das stattfinden wird.
Und erstmal überraschend, Frage ist warum und ähm die theoretische Antwort ist, man man gibt dem einfach einen Namen, diese Kraft, das was dahinter steckt, das ist die dunkle Energie und das hat der Einstein schon damals neunzehnhundertfünfzehn in seinen Feldleichungen.
Beschrieben werde zu viel gesagt, er hatte ja keine Ahnung davon, aber er hatte damals eine konstante eingeführt, als er mit einem Feldleichung aufgeschrieben hat,
die das auch beschreiben kann. Er hatte das damals eingeführt, um ein statisches Universum zu ermöglichen, also dafür brauchte er halt auch was, was der Gravitation entgegenwirkt, damit das Universum so bleiben kann, wie es ist,
hat es dann wieder verworfen, berühmte Geschichte, als er gemerkt hat, das Universum dient sich aus. So, aber heute benutzen wir es wieder, daher das Lamba. Ähm dann Kult Dirk Meta,
Das ist die dunkle Materie. Die andere große Leerstelle in unserer Kosmologie. Ähm die Erkenntnis, die neunzehnhundert.
Dreiunddreißig glaube ich begann als Fritz Zwicki,
Ein Schweizer Astronom feststellte, dass in Galaxienhaufen sehr viel mehr Materie existieren muss als die, die man sieht,
Also er hat einfach nur geguckt, wie schnell bewegen sich die Galaxien, ähm welche Materie sehe ich und sein,
Resultat war, die bewegen sich so schnell, die müssten eigentlich auseinander fliegen, weil die Gravitation aus der sichtbaren Materie nicht ausreicht, um sie zusammenzuhalten.
Also muss es mehr geben, war nicht klar, was es ist. Er hat's damals dunkle Materie sogar auf Deutsch genannt und das ist, wie wir es immer noch nennen,
Das hat man damals in anderen Galaxienhaufen beobachtet, dann mehr oder weniger parallel hat man's auf der Basis von Einzelgalaxien beobachtet, auch da,
die Sterne, das Gas und der Staub, das bewegt sich alles so schnell, die Galaxien müssten auseinanderfliegen,
Tun sie nicht, insofern muss es Materie geben, die wir nicht sehen können, um das Ganze zu stabilisieren. Vera Rubin zum Beispiel. Einer der wenigen Frauen in der Astronomiegeschichte hat das rausgefunden ähm.
Und dann zeigt sich das aber auch auf den ganz großen Skalen, auf den kosmologischen Skalen, wenn man sich anguckt, wie sich die Galaxien zueinander verhalten, also das Cosmic Web, so dieses diese große Netzstruktur, die wir beobachten, wenn wir,
Universum auf großen Skalen beobachten, also wie die Galaxien zusammenhängen. Das würde nicht so aussehen, wenn es nicht dunkle Materie geben würde,
Insofern sehr, sehr viele Hinweise, dass es da was gibt, aber das Komische ist, ähm, wir können nur sagen, es ist Materie, die ganz anders ist, als die, die wir hier aus irdischen Laboren kennen.
Sie ist auch anders als die Materie, die von unseren Theorien der Teichenphysik beschrieben wird.
Aber wir wissen nicht, was es ist. Und seit Jahrzehnten wird danach gesucht. Ähm seit Jahrzehnten wird auch jeden Moment damit gerechnet, dass sie gefunden wird, aber wurde sie bisher nicht und.
Nicht stattgefunden.
Wächst.
Ja, beziehungsweise ich meine, das ist ja auch schon mal interessant, äh man nennt es halt Materie, weil.
Von Materie, also Materie ist das Wort für das, von dem man weiß, dass Gravitation ausgeht. Hier hat man etwas, was Gravitation irgendwie bewirkt, also.
Wie sagt man, hat oder äh wie nennt man denn das.
Ja. Ein Gravitationsfeld erzeugt.
Genau, was ein Gravitationsfeld äh erzeugt und ähm könnte ja sein, dass man auch am Ende auf irgendwas trifft, was man dann gar nicht mehr Materie nennen will.
Na ja, aber es verhält sich halt mathematisch wie Materie. Also in einstelligen Fälltgleichung hat man da halt sozusagen einen Ort, wo man die Baterie hinpackt und da packt man auch die.
Was sagt das schon aus? Das ist doch nur Mathematik.
Für ein Skeptiker. Ich glaube, du bist nicht Physikalist.
Meine auch bei dieser dunklen Energie könnte man ja sagen, na ja okay, wenn man irgendwie nichts nicht sieht, wie es irgendwie von innen äh wirkt. Vielleicht wirkt's ja gar nicht von innen und wir befinden uns sozusagen in so einem
Extrauniversellen äh Vakuum, was einfach das ganze Universum die ganze Zeit aufzieht.
Also das das stimmt schon. Also die dunkle Materie die ist durch Beobachtung relativ gut ähm eingeschränkt würde ich sagen. Also da hat man wirklich viele Randbedingungen. Man kann,
obwohl man nicht weiß, was sie ist, man kann schon ziemlich viel sagen, was sie sein muss,
So, das darf man halt nicht vergessen, das klingt halt immer so, als würden wir da völlig im Dunkeln tappen, ganz so arg ist es nicht,
da gibt's dann schon viele Randbedingungen so. Bei der dunklen Energie ist es tatsächlich sehr viel schwieriger. Also da gibt's ja auch noch sehr viel exotischere Theorien,
was es sein könnte und da ist man dann schon ganz ganz tief in der theoretischen Physik und sehr weit entfernt von Beobachtung,
insofern muss man dann auch unterscheiden, aber es ändert halt nichts an diesem erschütternden Resultat, dass letztendlich die Materie,
die wir verstehen und von der Erde kennen,
dass die nur rund fünf Prozent dessen ausmacht, was sich an Energie und Materie im Universum befindet. Und das ist natürlich kein besonderes.
Zeichen großen Erfolges, wenn man das so als als.
Können schon fünf Prozent von allem.
Also es klingt halt erstmal eher niederschmetternd so als Bilanz eines kosmologischen Modells und deshalb ist es so, dass.
Ich meine, grundsätzlich ist es ja bei Wissenschaftlern immer so als Wissenschaftler freut man sich ja über offene Fragen. Es ist ja toll, wenn man Dinge nicht versteht und insofern ganz viel Arbeit hat,
weil man nach Antworten und nach Antwortansätzen suchen muss. Aber an der Stelle ist es dann doch ein bisschen arg und es ist halt auch so, dass es wirklich seit Jahrzehnten keine richtigen Durchbrüche gegeben hat. Also am Anfang war die,
weil der Optimismus ja noch recht groß, dass man dass man zumindest in Beschleunigern was findet.
Also dass man irgendwie Teilchen erzeugen kann. Ich meine, warum sollte es Automate nicht auf der Erde geben? Irgendwo muss sie hierher kommen, also dass man die in irgendwelchen Kollisionsprozessen erzeugen kann und dass man dann eine Ahnung hat, was es sein kann.
Da gab's auch ein paar und gibt's auch ein paar tolle Kandidaten aus der Teichenphysik, wo man sagen würde, das wäre ganz großartig. Die würden alles genau erklären, wie wir es haben müssen und das wäre auch theoretisch noch schön und,
wäre ganz wunderbar eine ganz schöne theoretische Erweiterung, weil die Teichenphysik hatte auch ihre eigenen Probleme, also man idealerweise in einer idealen Welt würde die Lösung für,
für das dunkle Materieproblem nicht nur die Probleme der Astrophysiker lösen, sondern auch gleichzeitig die Probleme der Teichenphysikeit gleich mit und dann wären alle happy. So und das hat man auch irgendwie erwartet,
aber es kam anders. Und da hat der Lard Shadon Co leider dieser große Teilchenbeschleuniger in der Nähe von Genf.
Auch nochmal für eine ziemliche Stimmungsverschlechterung gesorgt, denn da war man eigentlich schon davon ausgegangen, ich meine gut, man hat es zur Sixposion gefunden.
Aber es ist halt genauso, wie man's erwartet hatte und das ist natürlich auch blöd, denn es ist wäre.
Ist langweil.
Also wäre wirklich schön gewesen, wenn man da Anhaltspunkte bekommen hätte, an welcher Stelle was nicht passen könnte. Und das hat sich aber einfach alles bestätigt und man ist letztendlich ähnlich schlau wie vorher. Und dadurch hat sich in der ja in der,
Theoretiker-Community und auch in der kosmologischen Community.
Denen, die nicht immer noch diesen Drive haben, von wegen, da sind die großen offenen Fragen, wir finden's toll. Doch auch eine gewisse Frustration ausgebreitet, bei den Leuten, die dann sagen, tja, vielleicht,
machen wir einfach ganz grundsätzlich irgendwas falsch, also vielleicht gucken wir einfach in die falsche Richtung, stellen die falschen Fragen, machen die falschen Annahmen ähm und das ist nämlich dann so ein Punkt, wo,
dann meiner Erfahrung nach auch wieder eine gewisse Offenheit der Philosophie gegenüber entstanden ist. Aus der Not heraus geboren in der Hoffnung,
zu sagen, hey ihr Philosophen, ihr habt doch so einen schönen Mitterblick auf die Dinge, ihr habt die guten Begriffe, um das alles irgendwie zu ordnen, helft uns doch mal, sagt uns, an welchen Stellen vielleicht irgendwie eine Annahme im Spiel sein könnte, die wir noch nicht geprüft haben.
Vielleicht haben wir nochmal ein paar der großen Fragen zusammen sammeln und uns dann nochmal so ein bisschen der Fragestellung äh widmen, inwiefern man das äh philosophisch angehen kann oder was was uns da äh was in der Hinsicht die Philosophie jemals für uns getan hat,
Also dunkle Energie, dunkle Materie, das sind ja so so die die großen schwarzen zwei. Wo würdest du noch so eine Kern
Problematik sehen der Wissenschaft und speziell natürlich auch der äh Astrophysik, wo es gerade einfach nicht weitergeht.
Na die ganz, ganz große Frage natürlich,
ist die nach der Theorie, die die beiden Pole unserer Realität zusammenzubringen, vermark also den Mikro und den Makrokosmos. Das ist ja,
Eine weitere offene Flanke der Physik, dass wir.
Die Quanten.
Genau. Also wir haben zwei großartig funktionierende Theorien,
die hochgradig empirisch bestätigt wurden und einfach gut funktionieren, die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie, die auch rein ästhetisch keine Wünsche offen lässt
die Quantentheorie, die ja auch wunderbar funktioniert. Ich mein
Klar, da kann man, das hat dann wieder seine eigenen philosophischen Probleme, aber die kann man auch gut ignorieren, wenn man das möchte. Aber sie passen halt einfach nicht zusammen. Und da würde man denken,
Das ist sowieso schon unschön.
Aber es wirkt auch nicht besonders plausibel, denn es gibt ähm Phänomene, in denen beides zusammenkommen muss. Also zum Beispiel so ein schwarzes Loch,
Das hat auf der einen Seite Quantentheoretische Eigenschaften.
Hat ja Haking zum Beispiel beschrieben. Auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich ganz klar ein Gravitationsphänomen. Und da würde man denken, wenn man,
so ein schwarzes Loch wirklich genau beschreiben möchte, da braucht man eine Theorie, die beides vereinheitlichen kann. Und sowas haben wir nicht. Und das,
natürlich eine weitere Kränkung und da wird viel geforscht, viel probiert, String-Theorie, Quantim Blue Gravity. Ähm auch da fehlt noch der entscheidende Durchbruch.
Und ähm ja es ist interessant wohin das führt. Also letztendlich ist es tatsächlich so man hat an vielen Stellen so ein ähnliches Problem wo man,
quasi genötigt wird, sich philosophisch Fragen zu stellen, auch darüber, welche Ansprüche wir an Wissenschaft überhaupt stellen können als Menschen,
und aber auch an die Ästhetik von wissenschaftlichen Theorien, an die Leistungsfähigkeit, ich meine, wenn man jetzt ganz pessimistisch wäre, könnte man ja auch sagen,
Wir sind schon ganz schön weit gekommen als Menschen. Das ist ja schon auch ziemlich unglaublich, was wir so alles beschreiben können, was wir uns ja nicht mal am Rande vorstellen können. Also muss man ja nur Quantentheorie und relative Theorie nehmen. So wer kann sich schon eine vierdimensionale Raumzeit wirklich vorstellen?
Unglaublich, dass wir das theoretisch mithilfe der Mathematik beschreiben können. Es kommt was Sinnvolles raus. Unsere Navigationssysteme funktionieren, aber es ist weit jenseits menschlicher Anschauung.
Aber vielleicht und das ist dann wiederum der Pessimist, vielleicht haben wir dann irgendwann eine Grenze erreicht, wo man sagen muss, okay, das sind wir jetzt als Menschen nicht in der Lage mehr zu verstehen. Würde man als Wissenschaftler natürlich nie unterschreiben.
Da glaube ich auch nicht, dass wir so schnell aufgeben.
Nee, absolut nicht, aber ich meine, es ist natürlich eine interessante Frage. Und dann, wenn man jetzt nicht ganz so pessimistisch unterwegs ist, wäre dann,
Vielleicht die Anschlussfrage ähm muss man an irgendeiner Stelle dann vielleicht,
Wissenschaft verändern und da könnte man ja dann einfach sagen, das war eine eine Diskussion, die es vor ein paar Jahren auch gab, dass man sagt, vielleicht ist einfach die empirische Wissenschaft irgendwann am Ende. Es ist ja auch irgendwie naheliegend, also schon allein das Beobachtbare in Universum,
Das hat ja eine endliche Größe, was jenseits von dessen Grenzen ist.
Der Bereich des Universums, der einfach zu weit entfernt ist, ist, dass Signale von dort uns schon erreicht haben könnten. Ähm.
Der ist wie gesagt endlich dieser Bereich und dass man dann sagt, ja gut, vielleicht können wir dann einfach auf der Grundlage von empirischen Daten nichts mehr sagen, aber wir haben ja immer noch die Mathematik.
Wir können mit Hilfe der Mathematik das Universum beschreiben, aber das ist dann natürlich eine andere Art von Wissenschaft.
Bevor wir äh zu sehr äh uns in dieser ähm
Definitionsfrage äh verfangen. Ich wollte sie nur mal kurz so ein bisschen innoverieren, um mal so eine Forschung davon zu bekommen.
Wie viele große Spielplätze äh der der offenen Fragestellung.
Also wir hatten Druck der Energie dunkle Materie. Wir haben sozusagen die Suche nach einer vereinheitlichten Theorie der der beiden großen bewiesenen praktisch funktionierenden äh Theorien einsteigen auf der einen Seite Quantenmechanik auf der anderen Seite
wo man eben weiß, okay.
Können auch nicht vollständig separat voneinander existieren, weil's eben Beispiel schwarzes Loch Phänomene gibt, wo man weiß da finden sie mehr oder weniger auch gleichzeitig äh stark. Ich glaube, das was du angesprochen hattest, hauke mal diese Hocking
schwarze Loch dann am seinem Rand dann doch noch irgendwie wieder etwas zurückschickt auch wenn man ja immer diesen Blick hat auf das
schwarze Loch, das ist sozusagen alles verschlingt gepaart natürlich mit der Angst, dass wir dann auch irgendwann in einem Fell sinken, aber ich glaube, dass,
so schnell nicht strötter, dringend vorher noch selber um. Ähm,
was ist so eine weitere Frage? Also diese Expansion des des Universums, das hast glaube ich gerade angesprochen, ist ja äh abgesehen davon von dieser Beschleunigung, also
abgesehen von der Energie, die auf die es
zu wirken scheint oder die aufs äh es zu wirken scheint, ist halt überhaupt die Frage, wo kommt's her, wie viele gibt's äh davon, was ist dahinter, was war davor.
Ja, ich also letztendlich spielt das ja auch ein Stück weit in das Cosmologische Modell mit rein diese Frage ähm.
Einfach weil man ja.
Man man leitet ja ziemlich viel, einfach aus den Daten ab, die man hat über das beobachtbare Universum. Wenn das jetzt jenseits der Grenzen des Beobachtbaren ganz anders aussehen würde, dann müsste ja unsere Theorie auch völlig anders aussehen.
Das ist sehr schwierig zu sagen, weil äh man kann es ja nicht beobachten. Mhm.
Eben. Die Überlegung ähm dass man.
Sich. Also da muss man dann einfach kreativ sein und sich überlegen, vielleicht gibt es dann doch irgendwelche Konsequenzen, die das haben könnte,
an die wir jetzt erstmal gar nicht gedacht haben, so indirekte Konsequenzen, das wäre dann wiederum der kreative Teil der Wissenschaft. So, alles ist nicht ganz ausgeschlossen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein großes Problem. Äh dann also,
im kosmologischen Modell gibt's dann ja auch noch andere Probleme wie mit der Inflationsphase, wo es ja auch nicht so ganz klar ist, was da genau passiert ist und warum und so weiter. Ähm aber ich glaube, die ganz großen Fragen sind.
Tatsächlich.
Geleitet aus ähm der Frage nach dem Status von Quantentheorie und allgemeiner Relativitätstheorie und das ist ja auch letztendlich eine der Richtungen in die Kosmologen.
Gucken, zu fragen, ob vielleicht Relativitätstheorie doch nicht die endgültige wahre Theorie für den Kosmos.
Also das sind ja diese alternativen Graditationstheorien zum Beispiel, die versuchen durch eine Modifikation der Gravitationstheorie dunkle Materie überflüssig zu machen.
Hat man ja im Prinzip auch als Möglichkeit, ähm Schrecken hat die meisten noch davor zurück, denn die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie ist einfach wahnsinnig gut bestätigt und.
Hat eine sehr hohe Überzeugungskraft auch einfach schon allein von ihrer theoretischen Gestalt her.
Aber auch da wieder philosophische Klammerbemerkungen, Frage ist das ein ähm legitimes Kriterium, dass wir sagen, die Theorie sieht gut aus.
'ne schöne formale Form oder ist das wieder irgendein menschlicher Quatsch, der sich da eingeschlossen?
Geschlichen hat. So, aber das sind glaube ich so die die großen Fragen ähm und da kann es natürlich eigentlich jederzeit sein, dass es Beobachtungen gibt,
die uns überraschen und die dann plötzlich so ganz neues Feld eröffnen, eine neue ganz neue Perspektive, die dann vielleicht dazu führt, dass all diese Probleme sich auch gegenseitig zum Guten beeinflussen.
Jetzt hast du ja anfangs gesagt, Philosophie, okay, das ist so das Werkzeug, was uns überhaupt erstmal die Sprache gibt, äh die richtigen Fragen zu stellen. Um dann vielleicht auch auf die richtigen Antworten zu kommen,
War das jetzt mal auf dieses konkrete Problem überträgt? Das weiß man ja auch okay, einscheinen,
hat ja im Prinzip mit der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie äh auch nur in Anführungsstrichen Newton klarifiziert dessen,
Dessen Thesen ja sagen wir mal schon auch sehr weit getragen haben
bis man dann halt an die Grenzen gestoßen ist, hier so mehr Kurbahn und so funktioniert dann irgendwie nicht, wir wissen nicht so richtig warum und erst die weitergehenden Erklärungen von Einstein haben das jetzt aufgelöst und im Prinzip stößt ja dann Einstein selber,
mit seiner Gedankenwelt eben,
bei den Quanten dann eben auch so ein bisschen auf Granit und äh auf einmal lässt sich das nicht erklären und man sucht jetzt im Prinzip auf,
diesen weiteren kleinen Spin
irgendwie auf einmal alles magisch auflöst, aber man rennt so ein bisschen gegen die Wand und das geht ja jetzt auch schon eine Weile. Also es ist ja alles zwanziger, dreißiger Jahren hat sich das ja im Wesentlichen so manifestiert. Danach gab's ja dann eigentlich nur noch,
Phasen permanenter Bestätigung beider Theorien,
Und jetzt stehen wir da sozusagen immer noch da nach äh fast hundert Jahren und äh haben nix in der Hand. Das ist so ein bisschen der Ausgangspunkt. Was kann jetzt sozusagen eine philosophische Betrachtung hier helfen.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, die auch jetzt keine so ganz ähm offensichtliche Antwort hat. Also wie gesagt, es ist irgendwie die Intuition von beiden, von den Kosmologen, wie auch von den Philosophen,
Dass der Austausch irgendwie was bewirken kann, aber,
So aus der Intuition kann man ja erstmal nicht besonders viel ableiten. Äh da muss man dann gucken, was passiert, wenn die zusammentreffen. Und tatsächlich gab's jetzt auch einige Workshops ähm,
Konferenzen, wo es diesen Austausch gab. Man muss erstmal sagen, ähm bisher hat man jetzt noch kein Beispiel.
Ehrlicherweise, wo man sagen würde, die Philosophen haben jetzt genau.
Das fehlende Puzzlestein liefern können durch irgendeine Analyse. Aber ähm was da bisher vor allem passiert ist bei diesen Workshops war genau das, was ich gesagt habe, dass die Philosophen,
Versucht haben, mit ihrer Mütterperspektive so ein bisschen erstmal das Problem zu ordnen. Also also mal konkretes Beispiel ähm mit,
den schwarzen Löchern ähm gab's einen philosophisches PayPal, was ich ganz interessant fand, wo ein Philosoph einfach erstmal aufgeschrieben hat und dargestellt hat, dass die Definition von schwarzen Löchern die Astrophysiker und Kosmologen in verschiedenen Kontexten benutzen,
total unterschiedlich sind. Was für viele Missverständnisse gesorgt hat, ähm aber na ja immer die Frage aus welche aus welchem Blickwinkel man das Ganze,
definiert, ob man das, also die klassische Definition mit dem, das ist halt so so kompakt und hat so eine erzeugt so eine starke Raumkrümmung, dass nicht mehr Licht dem ähm entkommen kann,
so eine Herangehensweise, man kann aber auch ähm das irgendwie abstrakter über drei Ektorien aus dem unendlichen definieren. Also wo man dann irgendwie nur sehr viel mehr Raum zeitlichere Vorstellungen hat mit so einer Raumzeitturbologie.
Also ich bin da absolut keine Expertin, aber so einfach mal um den Flavor zu kriegen,
ähm und das da würde man jetzt erstmal vielleicht denken, macht keinen großen Unterschied, aber es macht dann doch irgendwie einen Unterschied. Also da gibt es dann kleine Unterschiede und da kann es dann schon helfen, wenn man jemanden hat, der sagt, hör mal, wenn du jetzt mit dem Kollegen B redest,
dann musst du aufpassen, weil der ganz andere Assoziation im Kopf hat, als du vielleicht mitgemeint hast.
Also das war was, was ich relativ handfest fand so als ähm Ergebnis einer solchen Austausch.
Ich kann mir das extrem äh nützlich vorstellen. Ich kenne das so ein bisschen aus der Programmierung, äh wenn man so äh mit seiner Software nicht mehr weiterkommt und dann rennt man einfach in irgendeinen anderen Raum und fängt an, jemanden, der noch überhaupt
gar kein, gar nicht weiß, wovon man redet, irgendwie zu erklären, was man da gerade macht und durch dieses
Sortieren im Kopf dieses, ich muss das jetzt irgendwie strukturiert ablegen hier äh in dieser Kommunikation sortiert sich dann der eigene Blick neu, weil man merkt, dass man,
quasi bisher die vollkommen falsche Herangehensweise, Abstraktion oder was auch immer äh gewählt hat. Und das kann ja dann auch so ein heilender Prozess sein an der Stelle.
Genau, also dann auch vielleicht nochmal Erwartungen zu klären, also mit dieser Darkmetter-Debatte zum Beispiel.
Nochmal genau zu fragen, welche Form von Argumenten werden denn da eigentlich aufgebracht? Also wie argumentiert die eine oder die andere Gruppe dafür, dass ihre Theorie die bessere ist.
Gibt's da vielleicht auch Momente, wo die einmal völlig aneinander vorbei reden oder kann man das irgendwie so strukturieren, dass man sagt, das ist ein Skalenproblem oder es ist, also da gibt's ja dann auch Vorwürfe,
Grade bei dem bei dem konkreten Fall, dass da Finanzierungsprobleme eine große Rolle spielen, also dass ähm Alternativtheorien nicht ordentlich gefördert werden und so
vielleicht auch die Philosophen sagen können, ähm das ist jetzt ein Argument, das ist auf einer ganz anderen Ebene, aber wenn das so wären hätte, dass die und die ähm Konsequenzen dann aber auch,
Gleichzeitig, was Philosophen natürlich sehr, sehr gut können, dadurch, dass sie in der Wissenschaftsphotosophie immer auch diese historische Perspektive im Kopf haben,
können die manchmal dann vielleicht auch sagen, es ist ja interessant, was ihr jetzt gerade für ein Problem habt, das hatten wir doch vor zweihundert Jahren schon mal oder vor hundert Jahren. Guckt euch doch mal an, was da so ausgetauscht wurde.
Ich freue mich ja die Leute, die jetzt in den letzten Jahrzehnten oder gab's ja äh zahlreiche Vorstöße, wenn ich das richtig sehe
so 'n Ansatz gewählt haben für eine Unified Sea so, also Strinkturia ist ja schon erwähnt, glaub ich nicht der einzige Ansatz, aber so einer der.
Gravity. So. Quantum Look Gravity wäre noch so anderes großes Lager.
Okay. Also da gibt's so verschiedene Hoods irgendwie und äh da sind die Leute dann halt so mehr oder weniger äh committed da drin äh so, aber,
Auf sowas muss man ja auch erstmal kommen, ne? Also es ist ja sozusagen auch so diese äh wissenschaftliche Leistung von Einstein erfüllt ja auch alle grade deshalb so so mit Ehrfurcht, weil.
Diesen Schritt zu wagen, überhaup,
Perspektive erstmal einzunehmen, dass einem das einfällt, dass man überhaupt erstmal sich selbst erlaubt und auf die Idee kommt, äh so zu denken, um dann eben zu dieser Lösung zu kommen. Das ist ja sozusagen das, was was,
äh den eigentlichen Nervenkitzel sozusagen dabei macht, weil es ja nicht so, dass man wissenschaftliche Theorien irgendwie, dass man irgendwo eine Schublade aufmacht, sagt, ach da ist sie. Also es ist ja etwas, was was einem,
in einem sicher auch erstmal formen muss. Man muss ja selber erstmal so eine ja, eigentlich eine eine Philosophie auch dafür haben, wie man jetzt seine Gedanken strukturiert.
Und deswegen frage ich mich.
Ist bei diesen Stringtheoretikern nur mal ein Beispiel äh äh zu nehmen, da sozusagen auch so ein so ein philosophischer Ansatz äh zu erkennen. Die müssen ja dann auch erstmal von irgendwo her sich das gedacht haben. Meine kennen die
teils nur so im Ansatz, aber was weiß ich, da müssen dann erstmal elf Dimensionen am Start sein oder sind's dreizehn? Ich weiß nicht genau. Äh.
Dort muss man ja erstmal seinen Kopf auch drumherum gefaltet äh bekommen, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Ähm das ist ja dann im Prinzip auch eine philosophische Leistung.
An sich um um erstmal oder basiert das auf Experimenten. Nein, eigentlich.
Ach so gemeint. Nee, also natürlich, das ist dann äh nicht empirisch in dem Sinne. Insofern hat man da tatsächlich eine Nähe zur Philosophie,
Philosophie wäre dann schon nochmal dazu nochmal die Meterebene, aber wenn man's jetzt nicht empirisch sieht, ja, also das ist ja genau die Frage, die ich vorhin schon,
auch kurz angetippt hatte. Die Frage ist das dann eigentlich wirklich das, was wir Wissenschaft nennen würden, wenn die Leute einfach irgendwas rechnen.
Und dann vielleicht auch sagen.
Matik, also.
Genau, wo sie dann vielleicht auch sagen.
Kann's gar keine Experimente geben und da würde dann Popper der gute alte Papa sagen, das ist keine Wissenschaft, denn wir haben da keine Möglichkeit, diese Theorie zu falsifizieren, da wurden aber diese.
Die Physiker, die Anhänger dieser sehr abstrakten Theorien sagen, na ja, das zeigt doch eher, dass Popper heutzutage nicht mehr angemessen ist,
denn es ist ja keine keine Lösung für uns zu sagen OK wir akzeptieren jetzt unsere Erkenntnisgrenzen,
So, wir haben einfach keine Daten, deshalb sagen wir darüber nichts, das ist ja einfach nicht so, wie wir Menschen funktionieren.
Ist raus so.
Papa ist raus. Papa konnte das halt einfach nicht ahnen. So, er ist ja heiß ja nicht, dass er doof war oder so, sondern er war halt einfach kein Prophet
In dem Sinne. So und aber natürlich macht das jetzt die Frage nicht einfacher, weil das natürlich immer noch eine Frage ist. Weil wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, Papa hat sich damals,
irrt, hat nicht weit genug gedacht. Wir akzeptieren jetzt auch so rein mathematische wissenschaftliche Theorien.
Papa hatte ja einen Grund, warum er dieses Abgrenzungskriterium eingeführt hat. Es war ja gerade seine seine äh Absicht wissenschaftliche Theorien von irgendwas anderem abzugrenzen. Also zum Beispiel von Theologie oder von irgendwelchen rein spekulativen,
Theorien. Wenn man dieses Abgrenzungskriterium jetzt nicht mehr hat, auf der Grundlage von Beobachtung.
Dann hat man das Problem halt wieder. So dann ist die Frage, warum ist jetzt so eine String-Theorie so viel besser als das, was die katholische Kirche lernt.
Da würde ich jetzt sagen, okay, da hat man natürlich Widersprüche mit Daten, wäre jetzt die Frage, so eine kleine wissenschaftliche Fingerübung, ob man jetzt den katholischen Glauben irgendwie sich so hindefinieren könnte, dass er nicht in Widerspruch steht mit empirischen Daten.
Ja oder kann man ihn nachrechnen, ja? Habe ich jetzt auch noch nicht gesehen.
Ja gut, dabei würde ich dann sagen, ja, ob ich jetzt ähm Mathematik benutze oder,
was würde ich, worauf ich da jetzt die, da bin ich jetzt auch theologisch nicht fest genug. Aber so, da da kommt man dann so ein bisschen ins Schwimmen.
Dann da wieder genau die Anfangsfrage, die wir hatten, was ist der Status der Mathematik? Warum,
Vertrauen wir Mathematik so sehr, wenn wir auch da nicht genau wissen, wo es herkommt. Also mit den empirischen Daten, mit den Experimenten, da ist man auf ein ziemlich guten Fundament. Man hat da einen festen Boden unter den Füßen, aber sobald man den verlässt.
Hat man halt so ein bisschen Rechtfertigungsprobleme in welche Richtung es jetzt geht. Und dann kann man natürlich sagen, okay, die Mathematik der vertrauen wir jetzt,
Genau, aber dann hat man natürlich auch in der Mathematik wiederum auch wieder philosophische Probleme, dass die auch nicht immer widerspruchsfrei ist mit Gürdel und so weiter, die Grundlegungskrise. Also das ist dann alles nicht ganz so einfach.
Ich wollte mit meinen Fragen bisher gar nicht so sehr darauf hinaus, dass ich irgendwie erwarte oder gar fordere, dass irgendwie die Philosophie alle Antworten lief,
oder dass sie sozusagen die Basis liefert, um jetzt irgendwie alle großen Probleme der Wissenschaft zu umgehen. Es kann ja auch in die andere Richtung wirken. Kann ja auch sein, dass,
Okay, das ist jetzt äh quasi mehr so eine Reaktivierungsfrage auch für die Philosophie, die sich bisher halt im Wesentlichen mit.
Abstrakten menschlichen Fragestellungen äh,
beschäftigt hat, jetzt auch äh sich selbst zu erweitern, hin zu einer naturwissenschaftlichen Disziplin.
Dass sie sozusagen Erklärungsmuster, Forschungsansätze, Ideenansätze vielleicht liefern könnte, wenn man da auf die richtigen Ideen äh kommt. Es ist,
auch vermissen.
Nee, also ich mein das ist natürlich genau richtig, was du sagst, dass ich natürlich, weil ich dann doch immer noch mehr Astrophysikerin bin wahrscheinlich von meinem Selbstverständnis als Philosophin,
dass das für mich natürlich die dominante Frage ist, die Frage, warum sollte ich mich überhaupt mit Philosophie beschäftigen? Ähm und da würde ich sagen.
Ist die Philosophie, die moderne Wissenschaftsphilosophie auch gar nicht wirklich weit von der Wissenschaft entfernt. Also diese philosophischen Fragen, die sind einfach Teil der wissenschaftlichen Praxis.
Da würde man dann vielleicht sagen, die die Philosophen haben einfach mehr Zeit und mehr Ressourcen, um sich damit zu beschäftigen, als die Wissenschaftler, aber die Fragen, die kennen beide, sowohl die Wissenschaftler als auch die Philosophen. Ähm für die,
Philosophen, also wenn ich jetzt aus der philosophischen Perspektive gucke, ist es auch ähm absolut.
Richtig, was du gerade gesagt hast, weil das ähm führt auch wiederum innerhalb der Philosophie zu gewissen Konflikten. Man hat halt diese lange historische Linie in der Philosophie.
Wenn gerade hier in Europa mit der kontinentalen Philosophie,
mit all ihren schweren Theorien, die auch ganz zauberhaft sind und ihren Reiz ausüben, aber die natürlich von Wissenschaft relativ weit entfernt sind. Also bei Kant kann man noch mit gutem Willen das so ein bisschen ein,
Ordner, jetzt haben wir gerade Hegeljahr, ähm, da wird's dann irgendwie schon bisschen schwieriger,
Da würde man sagen, das ist einfach sehr, sehr weit von der Wissenschaft entfernt und da ist es dann auch den Philosophen gar nicht mal so peinlich, wenn sie dann sagen würden, sie haben naturwissenschaftlich nicht viel Ahnung.
Was ist da bei Hegel so schwierig.
Ach, da sind schon einige Stellen, die ähm jetzt aus Naturwissenschaftlichem Blick gelesen, ziemlicher Humbug sind, so im Vergleich zu dem, was man damals wissenschaftlich.
Ähm so seine Vorstellung von Lichtheichen zum Beispiel und also das ist jetzt nicht seine Hauptschrift, aber.
Weiß ich was überhaupt, was du meinst, also weil ja sozusagen die auch die Philosophen in Abwesenheit von anderen Erklär äh Mustern ja auch immer wieder so ein Blick auf die reale Welt äh geliefert haben und sind nur eine Vorstellung dafür geliefert haben, was es denn vielleicht sein könnte.
Ich meine, die war ja schon immer da, die Wissenschaft und die reale Welt und aber es spielt insofern auch immer ein Stück weit eine Rolle, aber die Fragen waren einfach so, dass sie das ganz gut ausblenden konnten über weite Strecken.
Und wenn man diese prominenten philosophischen Positionen,
studiert und sich damit befasst, dann muss man sich nicht gut mit Naturwissenschaften auskennen.
Und ähm das hat ja auch zu so einer gewissen Kluft in der akademischen Landschaft geführt zwischen den Natur- und Geisteswissenschaften ist ja auch schon viel drüber geschrieben und erzählt worden mit den zwei Kulturen, die sich einfach gar nicht verstehen und sich nicht wertschätzen und
die Naturwissenschaftler finden die Geisterwissenschaftler ganz rückwärtsgewandt und kompliziert und blöd und die Geistwissenschaftler finden die Naturwissenschaftler ganz unkritisch und,
und äh seltsam, so. Ähm,
ist jetzt ist ja nicht völlig ausgedacht, so diese Einstellung, die findet man schon durchaus noch in der akademischen Landschaft. Ähm aber die Wissenschaftsphilosophie.
Natürlich dadurch, dass sie sich mit einer Wissenschaft auseinandersetz,
ähm keine Wahl gehabt als sich auf die Naturwissenschaftler, aber auch Geisteswissenschaftler. Ähm also die empirischen Geisteswissenschaftler, die gibt's dann auch,
Also sich auf diese Gruppen zuzubewegen und deren Sprache zu lernen, deren Denken zu lernen, sich mit den Theorien auseinanderzusetzen, weil sie ansonsten auch überhaupt gar nicht ernst genommen werden würden. Also wenn sich so ein Philosoph zu einem String-Theoretiker setzt,
und dann mit Mythen anfängt und sagt, alles andere ist mir zu kompliziert, dann wird das kein fruchtbares Gespräch werden. Ähm,
Insofern sind die modernen Wissenschaftsphilosophen wissenschaftlich auf einem sehr hohen Niveau unterwegs, aber haben dann auch wiederum das Problem, dass ihre traditionellen Kollegen,
Vieles von dem, was sie machen, gar nicht mehr so richtig verstehen und anerkennen können, weil die halt wirklich dann schon die Sprache der Wissenschaftler angenommen haben
und deshalb genau wie du sagst, es ist in der Tat so, es hat einen ganz neuen Aspekt in die Philosophie gebracht, der aber dann Philosophie intern wiederum für Spannung sorgt,
weil ähm die Wissenschaftsphilosophen sich den Wissenschaftlern schon sehr stark angenähert haben. Dann aber auch so ein Eigendefinitionsproblem natürlich haben. So was macht jetzt die Philosophie überhaupt noch aus? Warum.
Sind die nicht einfach Physiker geworden?
Ist das so ein akzeptierter äh Bereich jetzt in der Wissenschaft? Wissenschaftsphilosophie.
Mhm. Absolut. Also es gibt Unis, die diesen Schwerpunkt haben und ähm.
Das ist etwas, was vor allem in,
USA natürlich sehr stark ist, also hier ist die Community ein bisschen später so ins Rollen gekommen, aber ähm gibt es auf jeden Fall jetzt auch in Deutschland sehr starke Institute und es wird auch immer mehr. Also es sind ja einfach spannende Fragen und.
Gibt auch glaube ich ich glaube nicht, dass es dazu große Probleme gibt, Nachwuchs zu finden. Also es.
Ist ja schon, würde ich sagen, so, dass viele sich für Wissenschaft interessieren und dann auch gerne ein bisschen tiefer gehen wollen und das aber auch durch die Spezialisierung der Wissenschaften,
wiederum viele, die vielleicht sonst einfach Physik studiert hätten und Physiker geworden wären, sich dann irgendwann denken,
Ja, eigentlich so die grundlegenden Fragen, die ich am Anfang des Studiums hatte, die werde ich jetzt gar nicht so richtig los und die dann vielleicht irgendwie so ein über einen Umweg zu den Philosophen kommen, weil sie merken, da werden genau die Dinge diskutiert, die ich eigentlich wissen wollte.
Drehen wir da nochmal den Spieß nochmal so ein bisschen um und,
Schauen jetzt mal, wo denn in der Wissenschaftsphilosophie und speziell würde mich natürlich jetzt das, was ich auf die Astronomie oder Astrophysik bezieht,
wo zeidet sich denn ab oder wo hast du schon was mitbekommen, wo du sagen würdest, okay, das ist jetzt auch mal ein frischer Ansatz oder das ist zumindest mal solange wir
ähm diese großen Fragen nicht beantworten können mal äh ein ein hilfreicher äh ein hilfreiches Gedankenmodell um in dieser Diskussion weiterzukommen oder äh auch nur sozusagen diesen Zustand zu ertragen, dass wir noch keine Antwort.
Ja, das ist eine schwierige Frage, also wenn's da schon so einen klaren Kandidaten geben würde, glaube ich, dann hätten das auch schon alle mitbekommen. Äh weil ja einfach alle sehr darauf warten. Ähm also wie gesagt, das steckt ja alles noch sehr in.
Heißt das, dass jetzt äh was weiß ich, nehmen wir da jetzt mal sozusagen so okay, was ist das Universum als Ganzes so, ja? Weiß nicht, ob er noch philosophischer werden.
Als mit dieser Frage, ja, weil es ja sozusagen gebig Bang und äh Expansion. Das sind ja eigentlich auch nur so zwei Rahmen äh äh Bedingungen in der Zeit, die mal so stattgefunden hat, aber es erklärt ja nicht, wo es herkommt, was da vorher war, was danach sein wird, wenn überhaupt
so. Ähm.
Ist das dann sozusagen gibt's da interessante Ansätze, die sozusagen jetzt äh auch der vielleicht der Astrophysik dann auch Vorlagen liefern können, wie.
Ja, also da sind Wissenschaftsphilosophen sehr, sehr zurückhaltend und auch sehr bescheiden. Muss ich sagen. Das kann man auch kritisieren, aber,
die haben doch auch Respekt vor den naturwissenschaftlichen Theorien und den wissenschaftlichen Herangehensweisen. Also ich glaube.
Die Wissenschaftsphilosophen, die würden sich jetzt nicht hinstellen und sagen, hör mal, ich habe mir jetzt mal was überlegt, was vor dem Okner sein könnte, rechnet das doch mal nach oder so. Ja. Da sind die.
Ja, bescheiden und zurückhalten. Ähm die sind,
häufig eher beschreibend unterwegs, dass sie wirklich versuchen zu ordnen, was passiert und dadurch einen Beitrag zu leisten. Aber,
dass sie selber einen Vorstoß machen würden und sagen würden, denk doch mal in die Richtung, das ist wirklich sehr selten und da habe ich auch schon Kritik von Seiten der Wissenschaftler gehört.
Das ist natürlich erstmal toll finden würden, wenn sie da tolle, fruchtbare Ansätze geliefert bekämen, denen sie einfach nur noch nachgehen müssen. Ähm.
Aber bisher doch keine bekommen haben.
Es ist einfach ja auch alles so abstrakt und voraussetzungsreich.
Also unsere Wissenschaft und das ist natürlich auch Teil des Problems, die dass auch zu dieser Kluft geführt hat. Ähm,
Die erfordert so viel Ausbildung und Praxis und Erfahrungswissen,
Was man aus der Philosophie so einfach gar nicht generieren kann. Also es ist ja das eine diese Dinge in Lehrbücher nachzulesen und zu verstehen, das ist ja schon mal toll, wenn man das macht, aber man hat halt doch nochmal ein ganz anderes Verständnis und.
Ganz andere Beziehung zu den Themen, wenn man selber ein paar Jahre sowas gerechnet hat und mit Modellen operiert hat und.
Die Dinge sozusagen von innen kennengelernt hat und das ist für die Philosophen vielleicht auch gar nicht unbedingt hilfreich, sich das anzueignen.
Dann würden sie ja wirklich Teil der Community werden und diesen diesen Blick von außen, den sie so haben, also diesen relativ.
Ähm objektiven, ne, relativ ähm unbeeinflussten Blick,
von außen. Den würden sie damit ja aufgeben, aber ich glaube, die Furcht ist oder die Sorge, dass dieses sehr intime Wissen, die sehr intime Kenntnis der physikalischen Theorien, dass die dann doch notwendig sein wird, um.
Durchbrüche dieser Art anzuregen.
Mhm. Ja, ich sehe da jetzt so von meinem geistigen Auge so die beiden Lager, äh die einander stehen und die einen sagen, ja, was hat die Philosophie jemals äh für uns getan?
Mhm.
Umgekehrt halt äh auch ähm wo denkst du denn ist das Potential? Also.
Geht's hier mehr so um die Grenzen äh äh der Erkenntnis.
Die sozusagen eher die Frage, ob ob ob sozusagen überhaupt eine Antwort jemals geliefert werden kann.
Ja, ich meine, das kann natürlich auch ein Aspekt sein. Ansonsten.
Also wie du sagst, es gibt ja auch diese diese extrem kritischen Stimmen von Seiten der Wissenschaftler, die sagen.
Steven Hawking, die Wissenschaft ist tot, hat irgendwen irgendwann den äh die Philosophie ist tot und nicht die Wissenschaft hat irgendwann den Anschluss verloren an die Wissenschaft und ist deshalb nutzlos geworden.
Dann auch dieses schöne Zitat, was angeblich von Feinmann stammt, aber tatsächlich doch nicht, aber das Zitat, dass die Wissenschaftsphilosophie für die Wissenschaftler so nützlich ist, wie die Onnitologie für die Vögel.
Alles diese und ist jetzt auch also kann man nachvollziehen, dass man diese Position hat. Ähm, damit muss man sich dann als Philosoph auch auseinandersetzen. Ähm.
Natürlich auch auf die Astronomen. Ich meine, was kratzt es das Universum, dass das Rundum also auf sie draufschaut.
Aber ähm ja, ich meine, wie gesagt, ich ich bin da auch also,
Meine Intuition war schon immer seit ich angefangen hab Physik zu studieren,
diese philosophischen Fragen, dieses zurücktreten und darüber zu reflektieren, was man da macht, mit welchen Erwartungen, mit welchen Ansprüchen, dass das dazu beiträgt, bessere Wissenschaft zu machen.
Gleichzeitig muss ich auch zugeben, man darf es nicht übertreiben, denn in der modernen Wissenschaft ist man unter so einem Druck unter so einem Erfolgsdruck. Man kann da nicht beliebig viel reflektieren und nachdenken.
Also da reicht's dann manchmal vielleicht schon, dass man überhaupt weiß, an welchen Stellen man's gerne würde und sollte, aber da muss man dann nicht alle Details selber machen. So und da, da ist dann vielleicht ein Punkt, wo dann die Philosophen einspringen können, die sind auch wirklich dafür bezahlt werden, dass sie diese Arbeit machen.
Ansonsten muss man in der Tat sagen, uns fehlen bisher noch so die durchschlagenden Erfolgsgeschichten. Also ich würde jetzt gerne irgendwas erzählen, dass die Philosophen.
Eine Studie gemacht haben, PayPal geschrieben haben und dann plötzlich klar wurde, dass aufgrund dieser begrifflichen Verwirrung äh ein Problem überhaupt erst entstanden ist, was sich daraufhin aufgelöst hat. Also, wäre ja toll, wenn man sowas erzählen könnte.
Gab's bisher einfach nicht, so ich als empirische Wissenschaftlerin würde sagen, es spricht jetzt nicht unbedingt für den totalen Erfolg der Kooperation. Ist jetzt die Frage.
Ist es einfach liegt es daran, weil das noch nicht so lange praktiziert wird in der Intensität oder ist es ein grundsätzliches Problem? Kann man im Moment irgendwie schwer sagen? Ich glaube aber.
Da wiederhole ich mich gerne ähm dass einfach diese begriffliche Aufgeräumtheit und dieses total geschulte, logische Denken, dass die Philosophen praktizieren, dass das den Wissenschaftlern.
Problem und bei Fragen helfen kann, die sie sich sowieso stellen würden, wo sie aber einfach nicht die Zeit und die Ressourcen haben, dass mit der Regorosität anzugehen.
Da gibt's ja ein ganz äh typisches Problem, was äh derzeit, glaube ich, die Wissenschaft so äh hat und der sie sich äh glaube ich auch zunehmend gewahr wird, nämlich das Problem der Kommunikation mit allen Nichtwissenschaftlern.
Äh das erleben wir ja derzeit in den verschiedensten äh Ausprägungen äh ohne jetzt gleich äh das alles so dramatisieren zu wollen, was gerade so in USA äh abgeht oder sonst wie bei irgendwelch
Demos ist ja eine generelle Problematik, dass gerade diese,
also es gilt generell für jede Wissenschaft, aber ich würde mal fast sagen, so gerade was so das Universum und diese potenzielle Unvorstellbarkeit von allem betrifft und und auch so die,
schwierige Erfahrbarkeit für den einzelnen, klar, man kann da sich mal so ein paar Sterne im Teleskop anschauen, aber das dann dann halt auch irgendwie dann schnell äh äh endet und,
Problem war ja schon die Astronomen selbst,
ja? Trotzdem ist die Erkenntnislage ja relativ dicht und äh wenn man das auch so ein bisschen verfolgt, finde ich es auch immer wieder abenteuerlich. Also es ist ja so.
Es gibt ja erkennt neue Erkenntnisse fast im Wochentakt. Also es ist ja ich glaube die Vorstellung von Astronomie und und dieser ganzen diesen ganzen Forschungsbereich von vielen Leuten ist ja auch so dieses so ja alle zehn Jahre äh
es ist ja Schlag auf Schlag, es.
Mein Job.
Ballert, ja? Genau, du hast das da sozusagen täglich ne, also es ballert äh sozusagen die ganze Zeit äh äh rein. Trotzdem,
trifft es dann zwar auf so eine interessierte ähm Öffentlichkeit äh auf, aber es hat Schwierigkeiten in die, in die Gesellschaft so ohne Weiteres durchzusickern.
Und.
Das hat ja viel mit Vermittlungsfähigkeit zu tun und das hat eben auch was damit zu tun, dass es vielleicht nicht die richtigen Denkmodelle oder Erklärsysteme gibt, in denen,
diese neue Komplexität oder auch nur die bisherige bekanntere Komplexität irgendwie korrekt in die Breite kanalisiert werden
kann so. Und da würde ich sagen, äh aus dem, was du bisher gesagt hast, wäre das ja dann vielleicht auch mal ein interessanter Fokus für die Wissenschaftsphilosophie. Eben auch neue Erklärmodelle, für das, was wir schon wissen.
Zu liefern. Begrifflichkeiten, Kategorien oder eben auch Verständnishilfen, also.
Topwissenschaftler tun sich sehr schwer damit, nachvollziehbarer Weise, ja, ihrer Erkenntnislage auch äh zu vermitteln. So, ich
das ja auch an mir, ich bin irgendwie kein, ich hab das irgendwie alles nicht studiert, ich zieh mir das hier irgendwie so Schritt für Schritt über diesen Podcast rein, nimm natürlich noch andere Quellen äh wahr und trotzdem gibt's immer wieder so ein paar
Bereiche, die ich mir schon irgendwie dreißig Mal durch irgendetwas erklären lassen, aber wo irgendwie mein Hirn immer noch Schwierigkeiten hat, sich drum herum zu wickeln und das wäre natürlich an der Stelle, man sucht ja immer so nach guten.
Erklärmustern, erklär ansetzen, gute Vergleiche, gute Bilder und so und ähm viele dieser Bilder scheitern glaube ich und das wäre natürlich etwas, wo die Philosophie,
da das ja sozusagen ihr Kernbusiness ist, gute Erklärmuster zu liefern, zumindest verstehe ich das jetzt so. Wäre das ja dann äh eine interessante Aufgabe, der Wissenschaft, gerade in diesem kritischen Feld der Kommunikation mal unter die Arme.
Ja, ich glaube, die Philosophen würden das selber jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Obwohl es teilweise schon gibt, aber das ist natürlich genau das, was ich bei mir selber in meiner eigenen Biografie beobachtet habe. Also das war damals, ich hatte das ja kurz erwähnt mit dem Blog.
Die Geschichte dahinter, die war, dass ich einen Artikel mal hier geschrieben habe für die FAZ,
dass dann die Frage war, könnte man das vielleicht irgendwie ausbauen? Frage, wissen auch mehr schreiben. Und was sind Themen, die dich interessieren? Und da kann ich dann hier hin ohne Ahnung von Medien. Ich habe gesagt, ja, ich würde halt Wissenschaftsphilosophie ganz interessant, das wäre doch mal was Schönes.
War die Reaktion. Also,
Wir glauben eher nicht, Wissenschaftsphilosophie, also Wissenschaft ist schon schwierig, aber Wissenschaftsphilosophie, das wird keinen Menschen interessieren. Und dann gab's halt diesen Wissenschaftsblock, den Plankton-Block, der zu der Zeit sehr, sehr schlecht lief und quasi nicht befüllt wurde. Kein Mensch hat den gelesen und war dann,
so die Idee,
Weißt du, schreibt da einfach rein, da kann nicht viel kaputt gehen, das ist eh schon alles nichts und probier's einfach mal. So und da habe ich dann angefangen mit wissenschaftsphilosophischen Themen und das hat erstaunlicherweise funktioniert und zwar hat's dann so gut funktioniert, dass äh ich dann von da aus auch mal in die
Zeitung gelassen wurde und von da aus das dann weiter ausbauen konnte. So, aber da habe ich jetzt schon gesehen, es ist halt nicht so, dass Wissenschaftsphilosophie.
Unbedingt abschreckend wirkt, sondern
Man kann damit ziemlich viel anfangen in der Vermittlung. Und da muss man den Wissenschaftsphilosophen jetzt gar nicht unbedingt sagen, dass sie das selber machen müssen, sondern man kann ja diese Dinge, die es gibt, die Überlegungen und ähm die Begriffe kann man im Prinzip einfach schon genauso,
nutzen, wie sie schon existieren. Und deshalb ist für mich immer, wenn ich jetzt heute mit irgendwelchen Journalismusschülern oder so rede, die in Wissenschaftsjournalismus wollen, sage ich immer, ja, Wissenschaftsophie ist eigentlich eine super Ressource, weil man da schon,
einfach ganz ganz viel übernehmen kann und nutzen kann, genau wie du sagst für die Vermittlung. Und gerade wenn's darum geht, dann auch ähm die Einwettung von Wissenschaft in die Gesellschaft zu verstehen.
Das ist ja auch was, was man was Wissenschaftsphilosophen zum Beispiel auch reflektieren. Also was kann die Rolle sein von Wissenschaftlern? Dürfen die sich überhaupt politisch engagieren,
ja, was haben sie für eine Ligitimität? Also solche Fragen gibt's dann ja auch wiederum, die interessant sind. Ähm,
Und dann aber auch heute mit diesem wachsenden, ja, auch wieder diskutieren, aber mit dem vermeintlich wachsenden, mit der vermeintlich wachsenden Wissenschaftsskepsis,
die man in vielen Ländern verfolgen kann, dass man da überlegt, ist es nicht vielleicht schon auch wichtig, dass man den Menschen erklärt, wie Wissenschaft überhaupt funktioniert. Also vielleicht war das ja ein Fehler, dass man bisher immer,
sich sehr auf die wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse konzentriert hat und sagt, die Wissenschaftler sagen das und das und so ist es.
Ohne zu erklären, was für eine Methode dahinter steckt, weil wenn man diese Methode kennt und versteht, dann haben wir diese Ergebnisse eine viel viel größere Überzeugungskraft und das ist was, glaube ich, was ähm im Journalismus viel, viel stärker verfolgt werden muss, machen natürlich auch schon viele, aber wo dann auch
wiederum die Philosophen natürlich genau dabei sind, weil die hier, das ist ja genau das Thema, was sie seit hundert Jahren.
Ja, meine Vermutung ist es, checkt keiner. Also das ist wirklich so äh eine Annahme, die glaube ich die Wissenschaft so ein bisschen macht, weil man weiß, man ja, macht man ja den ganzen Tag, ist so
und ich selber, der an diesem Prozess so nicht teilgenommen habe, musste mir das auch irgendwie erst,
sukzessive so erarbeiten und bist dann irgendwann so drauf gekommen bin, warum redet denn da eigentlich da keiner drüber? Nehmen sie alle setzen das sozusagen gewisser Hinsicht äh voraus. Klar gibt natürlich dann Einzelne, die darüber reden, so kriegt man's dann auch irgendwann mal äh mit und
diese äh Power, ja, die gilt es auf jeden Fall zu kommunizieren, wo Rapper Kommunikation sind, du hast es ja jetzt schon angesprochen, welche Rolle siehst du denn
im Wissenschaftsjournalismus. Das schließt sich ja jetzt im Prinzip da, äh, direkt an, um dieses Problem anzu.
Na ja, mein Verständnis ist natürlich tatsächlich ein sehr wissenschaftsphilosophisches, also das, was ich halt immer versuche, ist schon auch eine Reflexion dessen, was Wissenschaftler machen,
einzubetten in einen größeren Kontext, dadurch dann einen Mehrwert zu schaffen, den die Wissenschaftler selber gar nicht unbedingt schaffen können, weil sie eben so spezialisiert sind und diesen ganzen Kontext gar nicht unbedingt im Kopf haben. Und dann finde ich persönlich das einfach,
Ja, wie gesagt, sehr sehr wichtig Methoden zu vermitteln und zu sagen, wie ist man zu diesem Ergebnis gekommen? Und dazu gehört ganz zentral natürlich auch zu sagen, was sind die Unsicherheiten? Also an welchen Stellen sind da wichtige Annahmen im Spiel? Welche Annahmen sind da überhaupt mit im Spiel,
und bis zu welchem Punkt kann man jetzt überhaupt sagen, es ist sicheres Wissen, an welcher Stelle wird dann wissen, was wahrscheinlich ist und warum ist Wissenschaft, obwohl sie so stark mit Unsicherheiten behaftet ist, trotzdem immer noch ein gutes Instrument.
Hast du da mal ein Beispiel dafür, wie du daran gegangen bist.
Naja, ich meine, was uns hier zu allen vor allem in den Knochen steckt, nach wie vor ist die Koronakrise, Kowit neunzehn. Ähm das war ja.
Für uns Journalisten eine sehr extreme Erfahrung, insbesondere für uns Wissenschaftsjournalisten und bei mir normalerweise schreibe ich ja vor allem über Astrophysik logischerweise, ähm als das losging, war dann relativ klar, ich kann mich da nicht ganz rausziehen,
weil es jetzt einfach ganz zentral wichtig ist zu unterstützen, zu erklären, was macht die Wissenschaft da, was ist der aktuelle Stand? Also bin ich damit eingestiegen.
Anfang an der Nachfrage gespürt oder war es erstmal nur so ein innerer Druck heraus irgendwie, oder muss man jetzt mal was erklären.
Also am Anfang stärker als äh später wahrscheinlich sogar, weil am Anfang ja die Unsicherheit so groß war. Keiner wusste so richtig was. Ähm es war eine,
ganz, ganz große, ein ganz, ganz großes Bedürfnis irgendwelche belastbaren Anhaltspunkte zu kriegen, womit wir es zu tun haben, was es für Wege gibt, was wir zu erwarten haben. Und ähm,
das thematisch war das natürlich von mir als Astrophysikerin erstmal relativ weit entfernt so mit einem Virus aber wo es dann doch sehr nah dran war an dem womit ich mich auskenne
war, dass es am Anfang natürlich ganz massiv auch um Modelle ging, um Modellierung. Wo ganz am Anfang ähm,
durchgerechnet wurde, also diese ganzen epidemiologischen Modelle mit der Frage, wie geht das weiter, wenn wir jetzt die Fallzahlen beobachten, was können wir hochrechnen, ähm was können wir an Maßnahmen einführen, was haben wir zu erwarten für die nächsten Monaten,
Und ähm das war was, was ich dann halt speziell versucht habe, also ich habe mit diesem Modelle dann wirklich im Detail angeguckt, also die ganzen,
ähm wissenschaftlichen Veröffentlichung wirklich auch in all ihren Untiefen und Tiefen und Supplements und Ergänzungsinformationen mir reingezogen, um zu gucken, was steckt da überhaupt drin,
dass dann versucht auch so zu vermitteln, weil ja natürlich am Anfang dann auch immer gleich die Frage war, können wir diesen Modellen überhaupt vertrauen. Und da ist die Antwort dann nicht so einfach. Man kann nicht sagen
Das Modell sagt die Wahrheit, wir müssen uns darauf einstellen, dass es in drei Monaten hier so und so aussieht, wenn wir das und das machen. Aber die Modelle sind auch nicht völlig nutzlos.
Denn sie rechnen dann doch Szenarien durch, die uns, wenn wir sie richtig interpretieren, Anhaltspunkte geben können, die wir praktisch nutzen können. Und diese,
Balance zu finden. Das hat glaube ich diese Krise gezeigt.
Eine Riesenherausforderung ist aber gleichzeitig sehr sehr wichtig, denn das merkt man jetzt ja auch, so wie die Wissenschaft mittlerweile ja sehr viel kritischer gesehen wird. Ähm die Öffentlichkeit fühlt sich nicht ernst genommen, wenn man ihr sagt, ihr müsst der Wissenschaft blind folgen,
logischerweise. Ist ja auch keine wissenschaftliche Haltung, in dem Sinne. Ähm aber es ist natürlich auch keine,
hilfreiche Haltung, wenn man sagt, es ist alles Quatsch, dann ja, ich meine, man sieht ja, wenn dann wo es dann hinführt und wir wollen einfach nicht krank werden, wir wollen keine,
keine Langzeitfolgen mit uns rumschleppen und wir wollen nicht unsere geliebten Familienangehörige verlieren. So und dafür ist es glaube ich ganz ganz wichtig und das habe ich versucht zu erklären.
Wie funktionieren die Modelle? Was sind die ähm also was können Modelle leisten und was können sie nicht leisten? Dann aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch ganz schwieriges Thema. Was können wir aus den Daten lernen,
denn das war ja am Anfang auch so ein Punkt. Alle haben auf ihre Handys gestarrt, jeden Tag die neuen Fallzahlen gehen die hoch oder runter, was können wir daraus lernen? Daten sind auch was, was,
sehr, sehr trügerisch sein kann. Die kommen so sehr unschuldig daher, ist halt irgendwie eine Zahl, was soll man da groß falsch verstehen. Aber natürlich ist es ganz relevant, wie die erhoben wurde, also gerade mit den Infektionszahlen haben wir jetzt alle gelernt. Es kommt darauf an, wie viel getestet wurde. Ähm.
Wie die Definitionen sind für Infektionsfälle, wer wird gezählt, wer wird nicht gezählt? Also all das muss man wissen, um so eine Zahl überhaupt verstehen zu können. Und da war ganz, ganz viel Aufklärungsarbeit nötig und ist auch immer noch nötig und das sind Dinge,
die ähm ja erstens ein gewisses Hintergrundwissen,
Über Statistik und Modellbildung ähm benötigen und auf der anderen Seite glaube ich schon auch davon profitieren, wenn man so diesen reflektierenden, abstrakten Blick aus der Philosophie mitbringt.
Ja, gleich absolut nachvollziehen, wenn man es jetzt nochmal auf die Astronomie oder äh sonstigen Astron physikalischen äh Nachrichten der letzten Wochen, Monate oder Jahre äh,
zieht so, gab ja so diverse große Ereignisse, also mal sagen, was wäre ein gutes Beispiel. Die Berichterstattung über dieses Abbild des schwarzen Loch.
Das hab ich ja hier auch bei Raumzeit schon so thematisiert, aber da hab ich auch schnell gemerkt so oh wow also,
schwarzes Loch erstmal so erklären dann äh ist auch noch in einer anderen Galaxis und ähm sieht man aber eigentlich nicht und jetzt sieht man aber doch was äh und was bedeutet denn das irgendwie.
Uns und so.
Das Loch.
Äh weiß nicht, ob du zu dem Zeitpunkt hier schon äh äh damit befasst warst, äh so also wie wie gehst du da vor
wie vermittelt man das jetzt sozusagen? Also erstmal muss man entscheiden, was vermittelt man überhaupt davon? Sowas lässt man mal weg, was nimmt man mit rein und dann kann man ja nicht einfach alles nur aufzählen, sondern man muss ja dann auch irgendwie kontextualisieren und man muss dem ganzen Jahr vielleicht eben auch so ein philosophisches,
so einen Überbau geben, so eine so Struktur.
Also konkret bei dem Beispiel, da war ich schon hier, war natürlich eine riesen Geschichte, die für ein paar,
Also insbesondere für einen sehr stressigen Tag gesorgt hat, weil man ja erstmal nicht genau wusste, was sie jetzt beobachtet haben, welches schwarze Loch auch wann ja irgendwie klar war. Sie haben ein schwarzes Loch gesehen. Ähm so meine Herangehensweise war, ich habe tatsächlich einen Artikel fürs Föter geschrieben, das ist ja auch noch immer so eine,
gewisse Ehre, wenn man dann für die Kulturliebhaber was schreiben darf.
Insofern ist dann da nochmal die ähm Messlatte ein bisschen höher gelegt, was Verständlichkeit und so weiter angeht. Und da habe ich das so aufgezogen.
Warum ist die Messlatte da höher?
Nee, man kann ihn nicht mit technischen Details vollballern. Also wenn ich für unsere Leser unserer Wissenschaftsseiten, Natur und Wissenschaft was schreibe, dann weiß ich, da sind auch Freaks dabei,
die finden das eigentlich auch ganz cool, wenn sie so das letzte,
Viertel des Textes vielleicht nur noch erahnen können, was damit. Also ich versuch's normalerweise nicht auszureizen, aber die sind sind sehr geduldig, was sowas angeht. Während die Fütterung dieser haben da gar keine Geduld, die finden das dann, glaube ich, einfach ärgerlich und.
Überflüssig. So, warum sollte man sich hier mit technischen Details aufhalten? Die wollen halt einfach wissen, was es bedeut.
Okay, also einfach ein bisschen was. Okay, dann da liegt die Latte natürlich dann nochmal extra hoch. So und jetzt wird's ja wirklich eine philosschophisische Frage.
Und so wie ich das dir die Seite hängt da tatsächlich auch an der Wand.
Oh, tatsächlich, das war jetzt echt Zu.
Also so wie ich das aufgezogen habe, ich habe dann eine Spalte gemacht, ähm wo ich die technischen Details erklärt habe. Also man muss natürlich schon auch wissen, warum ist das überhaupt so ein Durchbruch gewesen,
das ist ja, das ist ja zudem, also schwarze Löcher eh schon ein schwieriges Thema, aber dann ist es ja auch noch die komplizierteste,
Beobachtungstechnik, die wir in der Astronomie überhaupt haben. Also diese Kombination der Daten verschiedener Teleskope in der Phyrometrie. Man rechnet da ja im Foyerraum, so reicht schon das zu sagen, dann steigen schon eigentlich alle aus,
Da gibt's dann dieses schöne Bild, das man sagt, es ist so, wie wenn man von einem, wie wenn man auf einem Klavier spielt, wo viele Tasten nicht funktionieren,
Und insofern muss man dann aus den paar Tönen, die man hat, versuchen zu rekonstruieren, welches Lied man gespielt hat.
Sehr schönes Bild. Mhm. Fällt.
Sowas kann man dann halt nutzen, das ist natürlich auch wichtig, dass man das beschreibt, aber letztendlich muss man dann doch auch irgendwie einen Weg finden,
mitzuteilen, ähm ohne in diese technischen Details zu gehen, für die Leute, denen Technik einfach egal ist. So und mein Weg an der Stelle war dann in dem Hauptartikel ähm,
so aufzuziehen als ähm die Grenze zwischen dem sichtbaren und dem unsichtbaren, was sich für uns Menschen immer weiter verschoben hat, historisch.
Und das ist einfach ein weiterer Schritt gewesen, also schwarze Löcher waren ansonsten immer das, das Paradebeispiel für das unsichtbare, logischerweise, weil da ja einfach kein Licht rauskommt, so das kann man einfach nicht sehen. Und insofern ähm ist das ein,
ein sehr weit entfernter Meilenstein in der Verschiebung dieser Grenze zwischen dem sichtbaren und unsichtbaren für uns Menschen
in einer historischen Linie, die angefangen hat, äh sobald die Menschen angefangen haben, den Mikrokosmos für sich zu erschließen, dann den Makrokosmos natürlich auch, aber das ist ja ein eine Art Ordnungsprinzip,
Von Wissenschaftsgeschichte, dass man sagt, das was wir sinnlich wahrnehmen können, ist einfach immer größer geworden. Mit all den Unsicherheiten, die das mit sich bringt, weil natürlich auch immer die Frage war,
Also Mikrokosmos,
Wenn wir da jetzt was sehen, sehen wir das wirklich oder ist das eine Art de Factor aus unserer Technologie, die wir benutzen müssen, um sichtbar zu machen, wiederum dann die philosophischen Fragen,
da sind wir uns dann immer sicherer geworden, wo wir jetzt sagen, bei Elektronen haben wir keinen Grund mehr zu sagen, das ist vielleicht nicht real, was wir da sehen, ähm aber wenn man dann weitergeht bei den Quarks oder so.
War dann historisch noch später eine Diskussion. Können wir da sagen, das ist real. So und beim schwarzen Loch.
Interessanterweise ja dann auch wiederum eine ganz ähnliche Problematik, dass man da dann auch wieder sagt, die Technologie, die ist so kompliziert, die dahinter steckt. Ähm ist eine interessante Frage, warum wir wirklich,
glauben, dass wir den Schatten dieses schwarzen Lochs gesehen haben und ähm.
Eine ganz tolle Errungenschaft, dass wir es wirklich geschafft haben, jetzt diese Grenze so weit zu pushen. Und dann natürlich auch eine interessante Frage. Was kommt da noch als nächstes? So, aber diese Einbettung in diese historische Linie, das war das, wie ich das fürs Führeton aufgezogen habe in der Hoffnung,
dass ich darüber dann so ein paar, die sich zumindest für die Geschichte interessieren, vielleicht noch einfangen kann.
Und wie war denn der Follow davon.
Ähm also es hat sich hat sich zumindest keiner beschwert. Ne, ich glaube ähm.
Durchaus sind das, also das Interesse ist glaube ich manchmal größer als man das so denkt an diesen.
Naturwissenschaftlichen Themen, denn es ist ja offensichtlich, das sind Themen, die irgendwie eine Relevanz besitzen. Ich glaube,
Das Fremden, was man dann oft bei eher so kulturell ausgerichteten Menschen bemerkt, das hat dann viel auch mit Ängsten zu tun, dass das einfach gar nicht anschlussfähig ist, an das, was sie so interessiert und an das, was sie so wissen und wenn man dann zumindest,
die Bereitschaft erkennen lässt, dass man ein Stück weit auf sie zugeht. Ich glaube,
Dann ähm ist da ein großer Dank zu erkennen und ähm dann ist, ja, also ich glaube, dass diese Themen,
dass man da durchaus mutig sein kann und die auch noch mehr in den Fokus der Öffentlichkeit rücken kann. Selbst wenn's kompliziert ist.
Ja, Sybille. Haben wir denn noch ähm einen wichtigen Aspekt vergessen, den man jetzt hier nicht.
Auslassen äh sollte eine Perspektive auf dieses Themenfeld, was du noch gerne vermittelt wissen möchtest.
Hm, also ich meine, gibt's natürlich, wir könnten jetzt noch Stunden weiterreden, aber nee, ich glaube, also sowas.
Wir ja. Also Frage ist, wenn man sich dann nur noch wiederholt.
Ne, würden wir nicht. Aber nee, ich glaube jetzt irgendwie was ganz Dringendes. Ich kann eigentlich nur alle ermutigen, mal einen Blick in diese,
in diese Bücher und Veröffentlichungen zu werfen,
Wenn sie auch aus der Astronomie und Astrophysik kommen, denn es ist wirklich erstaunlich anschlussfähig. Also viele entwickeln ja so eine gewisse Abwehr der Philosophie gegenüber auf der Grundlage dessen, was man in der Schule so lernt und das ist manchmal beliebig ähm absurd, was man da so vorgesetzt be.
Bücher meinst du denn jetzt? Also.
Also entweder gut ich meine die meisten.
Die Kenntnis der Wissenschaftsphilosophen, die endet bei den meisten, glaube ich, mit Popper. Also einfach mal zum Beispiel Kuhn zu lesen, einfach weil's interessant ist.
Aber Popo ist heraus, haben wir ja schon gehört.
Jürgen ist trotzdem interessant, das zu lesen, also ist auch sowieso immer gut, die da nochmal im Original zu lesen, weil die ja dann doch meistens noch ein bisschen komplexer und differenzierter sind, als man so denkt, so, aber also Tom ist cool, finde ich, ist eine sehr interessante Lektüre
dann aber auch, ich meine einfach so Übersichtsbücher, über Wissenschaftsphilosophie ähm,
oder auch, ich meine, kommt ja immer darauf an, was man, wofür man sich interessiert, auch Philosophie der Mathematik, wenn man jetzt nochmal genauer wissen will.
Die auf zwei plus zwei gleich vier auch für Aliens gilt oder nicht. Ähm oder auch die Frage, was ist eigentlich ein Naturgesetz? Ist ja dann so ähnlich wie die Frage nach der Mathematik,
ähm ist das etwas, was das wirklich in der Welt gibt oder ist es was, was wir nur finden und so weiter. Also da gibt's unheimlich viele Bücher, die auch,
Wenn sie als Einführung geschrieben sind, glaube ich, ganz gut zugänglich sind für nicht Philosophen und ähm,
da würde ich mal dafür plädieren, dass man da einfach mit Neugier rangeht und einfach mal guckt, ob man da interessante Anregungen finden kann.
Das war jetzt aber ein Appell, der mir so in die äh in das Lager der Astronomen gerichtet ist.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Philosophen hören euch so?
Ja, es gibt ja sozusagen noch Leute, die weder das eine noch das andere sind.
Ja gut, ich war jetzt mal davon ausgegangen, dass zumindest eine Astronomieinteresse ja wahrscheinlich da ist und kein Raumfahrtinteresse. Ähm die Philosophen.
Ja, ich meine, also wer sich nicht für Astronomiethemen interessieren und begeistern kann, der. Ich glaube, Philosophen, die sind sowieso meistens schon relativ begeistert von diesen Themen. Also die Wissenschaftsnahen Philosophen,
und da muss man, glaube ich, gar nicht so viel Werbung machen. Aber natürlich, Astronomie, Astrophysik, Raumfahrt, großartige Themen und ähm.
Auf jeden Fall.
Immer den Podcast hören.
Deswegen sitzen wir hier.
Okay, jetzt erstmal vielen Dank. Ja, vielen Da.
Okay, sie bitte, dann sage ich erstmal vielen Dank für die äh Ausführung hier. Interessanter äh.
Einblick in ja mal auch andere Gedankenmodelle, die man noch mit in die wissenschaftliche Arbeit einbringen kann, aber auch die vielleicht noch zum Verständnis der Wissenschaft weiter beitragen können.
Übrigens habe ich auch ein Buch geschrieben, aber das ist natürlich immer mit Eigenwerbung, aber auch nochmal so über die Philosophie, Astrophysik und so weiter. Also das ist wirklich eine Einführung für, ich habe die für meine Eltern geschrieben, die mit beiden Themen nicht viel zu tun haben.
Und ja, also ich würde jetzt nicht als erstes mein Buch.
Haben sie es gelesen.
Das haben sie tatsächlich gelesen, ja.
Erkenntnisse haben sie dann dara.
Dass sie jetzt etlich verstehen, was ich so über weite Strecken meines Lebens bisher getan habe. Mehr können Eltern ja eigentlich kommen,
kaum wollen. Nee, also ich meine, das ist jetzt auch schon ein paar Jahre alt, das ist nicht veraltet, aber es gibt viele gute Bücher, man muss das nicht unbedingt meins lesen, aber so das.
Das Universum und ich die Philosophie der Astrophysik im Hansa Verlag erschien. Ähm oder viele andere Bücher. So, aber.
Versucht. Gut. Vielen Dank und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Das war's. Einundneunzigste Ausgabe.